Psych!
No loop here!
Yay!
I lost a nap, gotcha.
I have lost the nap, gotcha.
Yet again.
I don't know how.
Adventure, why are the odds against me?
Why?
I swear it worked one time it worked one time and it felt so good and like I've been chasing that high ever since guys I told myself one day I'll remember how it feels again I just it'll happen eventually guys the odds are like 100 000 but it's in my favor i can feel it it it will be it'll be the next one i swear the next one i'm gonna feel it again it'll be it'll be like i've reached like nirano and it finally happens guys but anyway also welcome to tomato farm doctor welcome welcome Anyway,
hello everybody.
Today we are going to be finishing Batman.
Yes.
I don't know how much I have left, but you guys told me, like, it was like, we're almost there.
And I was like, it was like, what, two to three hours left of the game.
And I was like, fuck it.
We're going to move it to the, I was going to move it to the next time.
And today's the next time.
I already forgot all the controls because we didn't have to wait.
Last week was fucking crazy for me.
Last week.
Last week was insane.
There was a lot.
so much stuff I don't know how I survived last week today today we are back with Batman I will have to say for those who are looking through like we saw a schedule for this week Saturday we are rescheduling Saturday's our greatest dream with Altair and Beto to the next week um it might be next Saturday it might be earlier I'm not sure yet um because Beto um it's a little awkward because like i posted my schedule because i was like all right i've i i've like delayed it a bit like there's no way it's gonna get rescheduled like it's it's three in the morning there's no way it's gonna be rescheduled because like i waited for full confirmation to like post it and then literally an hour later eltair was like oh Oh,
this is awkward, but Beto can't make it.
Something came up.
Oh, man.
I was like, bro.
I waited till 3 a.m.
Bro.
What do you...
I waited till...
Yeah, no, no.
Like, Beto's like, bro, my bad, man.
My bad.
No, no.
It wasn't Beto.
fault it wasn't bedo's fault um because like uh i asked altair first and then i think altair assumed we were all good to go like because like i was like oh hey we can add bedo because i saw bedo playing our creators and i was like who should we get as a third and then um and then i like altair uh just assumed that bedo was free this week so he's like yeah yeah saturday at 5 p.m that's good to go and then bedo was like wait a minute i'm not gonna be here on saturday well i said i was on a Saturday.
It was like, wait a minute.
I said I'm free, but I forgot to mention what day I'm not free.
so Bella was just like, was just not free on Saturday.
And by then I was just like, we'll just postpone it next week.
And so I don't know what to do on Saturday.
Maybe it'll just be me doing something else I don't know yet um um uh so we'll I'll figure that out later we'll figure that out later maybe it'll just be me out there doing some other fucking random games but I gotta figure out like what perms does he have too like that's like um that's the hardest part is just figuring out like what what games he can play like so so um so I gotta we gotta look through that or if not then it'll just be I'll maybe I'll do something solo I don't know yet also other than that um no soundproofing yet um apparently it's crazy but when you call on set on it's crazy I don't know you guys know this but when you call on Sunday regarding soundproof they don't do it on Sunday or like the next day you guys know that in the adult world you have to make appointments ahead of time isn't that fucking wild like like they can't just you can't just like be like what if I pay extra and you guys just come over today and they're like um ma'am um I don't get that's crazy I
like I was like what about tomorrow they're like ma'am next available date that we can come over and check your place is So we don't have sound.
Yeah, imagine that.
I can't believe people have, like, others to work before me.
Like, isn't that wild?
Like, I'm like, what the fuck do you mean I'm not your only customer?
You mean you have other customers to deal with and, like, that have already pre-arranged their appointments for you to come over?
Like, excuse me, but do you know I am the main character of this storyline?
How fucking dare they?
Anyway, uh, Doki was throwing at money, throwing money at the problem doesn't work.
All right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, thank you for the super chat.
Doki, I swear to God, this better be a natural Joker.
I'm going to find a way to hire a babysitter for you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you mean they don't live in the, what do you mean?
Is this not the Doki verse?
There's other people's lives in this Doki verse?
um anyway so i called him on saturday because you know i was just like hey you'll come over and soundproof my pipe you know no i obviously i was a lot more professional like i'm looking for soundproofing yeah because you come over and like check this place out and um they're like no we're gonna uh sorry man but our next also i'm like how many people here need soundproofing but It's wild because apparently like they do more than just soundproofing like Like it's not their main income so they do more than just sound it's not like a place That's just for soundproof so Because they're just like they're like handyman handyman basically Uh,
yeah, I was gonna say I was like what the fuck like How many people in this area need soundproofing?
uh but apparently like uh that's not like the only thing they do as well so um so uh i call them and they're like we can come over on thursday to exam like you know uh to like check your stuff check the place and like maybe we can do the soundproofing like oh yeah it's gonna be like how is there like millions of streamers here like so um so the they'll be here around on Thursday and uh and they're gonna check everything out out but I also had a really rough day yesterday I fucking hate my bank guys I know I told you guys how much I hate my bank but no okay I I wrote this rant to my manager so let me read this rant to you guys I'll read it word to word like I I'm not gonna tell you guys like a whole story I want you guys to the emotion of this call so all right so long story short I found out that one of my credit okay sorry I found out that my credit card doesn't work and I was like why the fuck is it not working because I was trying to make an online purchase all right here you go
I've been in a two hour call with this bank and apparently they locked both my cards because they thought it was fraud like someone took my cards and did random charges on it and now they have to send me a new card to replace it even though i said there is no fraud it is so frustrating i was wondering why i couldn't use it to pay for things but like it's been locked since August but sometimes the payment goes through and sometimes it doesn't how the fuck was I supposed to know it was locked I wasn't given any warning that it was locked I hate my bank okay so long story short so I was like why the fuck can i buy anything online with this card so so um so you know you gotta be in a you gotta wait you gotta be on hold where you want to fucking talk to your uh to your credit card uh line so i was i waited for two hours like just like like on hold but it was like a back and forth so like because like I was just like yeah um for some reason I can't uh I can't uh I can't like do anything
about my card because because like it won't let me pay for anything online so then they're like oh sorry ma'am this is the wrong um channel for that let me like redirect you like by the way before they redirected me they're like ma'am can you give me your full name all right what is the business,
what is your business name?
Okay, can you also tell me, um, how much credit do you have on your credit card?
All that information, you know, like, oh, and what is like the last four digits of your card?
And then they're like, okay, ma'am, what can we do for you?
And I was like, oh, um, so I can't make the purchase online on this card for some reason.
Um, and like, I checked the, my bank, I checked the bank account and it says I still have enough credit for it and she was like oh sorry this is the wrong like division for this let me redirect you uh to to like um the small business division and i was like oh okay and then bam gotta wait another 30 to 40 minutes on hold um and this is like like it was like 12 p.m by the way so so anyway so i waited and then finally i got hold and i was like okay so so yeah uh and they're like what can i do for you and then you know what is your full name man what is your full name what is your business name what is the last four digits of your credit card what is the phone number that you use that's associated with this business and i'm like pop pop pop pop pop and they're like okay ma'am let me check this for you and they're like oh this card has been locked since august for fraud and i was like what the fuck for fraud the thing is i never noticed it because i could sometimes use the card in person
so um so like it never like like thought like i just thought like sometimes like oh maybe like i'm the purchase was too high so i couldn't use it so i i was like really confused because I have used this card for other purchases in person and I never got a text or any a call or anything that told me that the card was locked but I realized wait I can't use yeah I checked my email too I realized like wait how come I can't use this card online because I had to make a big purchase online um and so I was like that's weird I was like that's weird because I was able to make purchases before on this card after August.
So how the fuck was I supposed to know it got locked?
So anyway, by the way, do you know why it was locked in August?
Because I was in fucking China and like using the card.
But like I was able to use it.
Because I looked at the dates and I was like, that's weird.
I was making purchases in China and the cart and it went through so um so I was just like why why the fuck was I locked for fraud when I was still able to make purchases in China like no it still worked so I was so confused because it still worked back then so I never noticed it but apparently that was the day they flagged it as fraud um anyway anyway so i was so confused i was like oh it's not fraud like i was traveling in china so like it it wasn't fraud like it's okay you can unlock it and they're like sorry ma'am in these scenarios since we've already flagged your card for fraud we have to send you a new card i was like but none of these purchases are suspicious so like i'm like i'm looking through these purchases and like i've made all these purchases none of them are suspicious what do you mean you have to send me a new fucking card so i was just like i'm like dude like man this is like it's just protocol but i'm like but it's not suspicious like i told you it's not fraud it's
not fraud is this really the only way like yes ma'am sorry um we have to but the thing is the card is still usable i could use this card in person i just can't use it online so is it is it terminated i even is the card actually terminated or not i don't know
so so anyway anyway so they're like we have to send you a new card because you can't we it's like protocol because we already marked that card as um we already marked that card as suspicious and like fraud so we have to send you a new card so I was like okay um when can I like you know I was like oh okay so when can I uh get this card and they're like oh you'll get it in a week and I was like okay I had that play I was just like okay I gotta figure this out because I was planning on using this card to pay for the soundproofing because it is a business expense so I'm like oh fuck okay if it gets too expensive because this one has like some more credit so i was just like can you check my other business card and because like i have a second business card but it's like for a different it's for a different it's under a different name under a different company name so i was just like can you check that one because for some reason i couldn't use this card to pay for things either um but like
i already paid it off the credit for this too so it should it doesn't have a that it has like 3k basically want the one they locked has a uh the one they locked has a 20k credit limit um which is a lot and that's why i like that card and then the other one the other one is for small purchases it has 3k credit limit so i so the thing is i wanted to use the 20k credit limit to pay for the soundproofing um and then the 3k for like small business expensive yeah so but then the thing is the
on the big card not the small card so i was just like but it still wouldn't let me do big purchases like it won't let me do big purchases or anything it's not really tmi it's just credit like limit it's a credit limit it's not really tmi um it's just it's like it's like um yeah but it's like depending on like for business expenses and stuff it's not like i spend 20k right off the bat purchase I have to make for my business you know like 3d stuff I'll use the I'll use the the big credit card uh so so um anyway anyway um uh I was like can you check my other card it's in Canadian by the way it's a Canadian bank account I fucking hate my bank account anyway so I was like is that one not because i can't do it the purchase with that because it's 3k and not because and you're like oh it's because you try to charge something that was 3 000 and 3 000 and 100 so the the payment didn't go through because you don't have enough credit limit for that and i'm like a fucking question like the the 100
was the what's the limit the 100 drew the line for that card So, like, that's why, so I, because I thought it was two cards got locked.
I was like, why can't I use my other card?
So, I was like, oh, well, um, does that, can you, like, you know, uh, maybe help me increase the credit limit for that card?
Like, I, like, at that point, I was just like, can you increase the credit limit on that card?
Because I might as well.
Um, I might as well.
And they were like, oh, that's not my division.
connect you to someone else so so so they're like i'm sorry man that is not my division i will connect you to someone else to to check if you can up your credit limit for that card so i waited maybe another 30 minutes and then i got got to a new person and they're like we go through the same rodeo the same the same merry-go-round what's your phone name um what's the what's the business name what is the last four digits of your credit card number what is the number associated with with what's your phone number associated with your business what oh and then they added something new this time um what is the credit limit limit that you have on this card you know And then so,
okay, I went through the hoop and they're like, what can I do for you today, man?
And I was like, I would like to increase the credit limit for this card because like I need to make a purchase and the limit for this card is a little too, is too low right now.
And I need to up the credit limit.
And she's like, okay, let me go check, let me go check and see if you have any pre-approved offers for your card.
then she was like, I'm sorry, ma'am.
You don't have any pre-approved credit upgrades.
So we're going to have you apply, apply to have a, we have to check your credit score.
Um, is that okay?
But we have to check your credit score and also have you apply to see if you are eligible to increase your credit.
And I was like, yeah, that's cool.
That's fine.
Fuck it.
I have the whole day.
It's the rest day.
I should say, okay, let me redirect you to someone.
Yeah.
Let me redirect you to the person that takes care of that.
So, I got redirected again.
And I'm like, why the fuck did this person, why the fuck did the person before take me to her if she was just gonna redirect me anyway regarding upgrading my credit?
regarding approving my credit.
Because apparently the person that checks if I'm pre-approved to have a higher credit is different from the person that checks my credit score.
Like, so I was just like, why the fuck is the two different people?
It should be the same division.
And they're both about credit.
It should be the same.
And then...
So...
Anyway...
I waited another 20 minutes this time.
Another 20 minutes.
Make it stop.
Anyway...
I waited another 20 minutes.
And then I got... I got punched in.
to a different division and she was like same thing what's your full name ma'am and i'm like why do none of you keep this record i'm like i'm the same person what's gonna happen i swap i change to someone new in between the on hold like there's a like when while we're on hold a new person takes over my phone so i'm like why are you still asking me this so so anyway Anyway,
again, what's your full name, ma'am?
What is your business name?
What are the last four digits of your credit card?
What is the phone number associated with your business?
Anyway, we got all that done.
And she was like, what can I do for you today, ma'am?
And I was like, oh, I'm here to, I got, I got, got directed here uh because uh because I'm trying to up my credit limit and then she was like sorry ma'am what can you repeat that I was like yeah I'm here to I I'm here to like up my credit limit for this card beep call dropped call
the call disconnected
they didn't hang up.
I looked on my phone and it said call failed.
So somehow I made it to the very end of the person I needed to talk to and the call fucking failed.
The moment she asked me finally, what am I, what do you, what can I do for you?
And I got there.
I wanted to, I got there, I said I needed to increase my credit limit, and then call failed.
I,
it wasn't, it was not even like she hanged up and literally just failed.
I got, my bars were like, bam, it's over.
We gave you false hope just to fuck with you.
And then I think I was thinking truly they'll call back right like I I was it was almost it was two and a half hours of being on hold and being like like redirected to every fucking department possible in this bank and I was like truly they'll call back right they never called back Guys,
they fucking never called back.
And I didn't want to go through it again.
I didn't want to be on hold again, guys.
But it was not over.
Because I don't know if you guys remembered.
But I had to go back to...
I had to go and call my...
pet hot my dog hospital again and regarding regarding the uh regarding like appointment and stuff for dad's like kidney thing and and like they're like sorry internal medicine isn't here right now so please leave a voice message i left a voice message the day before this entire fucking fiasco and um um like it was like around like 5 p.m i went to take a shower last like 5 p.m.
I got out of the shower and I missed their call and it was like 10 minutes ago.
It was 10 minutes ago.
So I was like, okay, I'll call you.
I'll hurry and call back.
And I was just like, okay, hey.
And then I was like, the receptionist picked up and they're like, oh, sorry.
You got, let me talk.
I don't know why you're, you're, you got redirected to receptionist.
Can you please be on hold for a bit while I try to get internal medicine to your call?
And I was like, yeah, that's cool that's no problem i've been on hold for like 90 of my day today so like what's one more hold gonna do to me um and then she got back to me and was like oh sorry i didn't turn a mess and got off for their day so we need i'll redirect you to their voicemail and you can leave them a message and i'm like thinking it was 10 minutes
They called me 10 minutes ago to be like, can you please call back so we could like make an appointment for dad?
And I was like, oh, cool, it's just 10 minutes ago.
Like, surely I can make this appointment.
But apparently in 10 minutes, they all left.
I don't know how.
They all fucking just left.
Like, oh, what's the point?
Like, why did they call me in the morning?
Because I left the voicemail the day before.
Like, yeah.
And so, so I was just like, I still haven't got my call back yet, guys, I still, but it's also Remembrance Day, so it makes sense because it's a holiday, but I'm like, how was I 10 minutes too late?
Like, how did they all just decide to get off work in 10 minutes when they told me, please call back soon so we can make an appointment?
And I was like, is 10 minutes not soon enough?
something like so that was my day yesterday now you can tell why I had to take a nap to recover from yesterday I'm still I'm still recovering from yesterday right now so I had to take my egg oh yeah I went by the way yesterday I need you guys to know I was not okay after I was so angry went you know those rooms where you smash things so yesterday I was just like browsing Google Maps and I found a room like a building where you can go in and smash the I actually it was pretty cheap though yes I went to the rage room yes I actually went to a rage room yesterday and they gave me like they had like crowbars and everything so yeah no it was it was bad like I was so mad yeah yeah I was so fucking I was like oh my god there was an actual angry room I was like oh my god like I need this right now I like it's cheaper than therapy for sure um but wait let me read you the the messages I sent my manager all right all right okay I didn't I hate my bank I was on hold for 20 plus minutes and then I
got through them and they asked all my info to confirm like oh your full name your business address etc and finally we got to the part where they're like what can we do for you and I said increase my credit line and then the call dropped and okay and then I was like the hospital called me back to make an appointment but I missed I was taking a shower but I was like 10 minutes late to the call so I called back instantly and then was told that they just got off of work and won't call me back until Wednesday so I have to leave a voicemail.
L-O-L.
I was literally 10 minutes late.
was that was my day yesterday at this point just go wide at the room i would pay for it on george thank you but let's see for chat thank you thank you but i'll show you guys i'll show you guys what they offered me in the in the rage room i so um they gave us like okay so so it was crazy because like um for the rage room they gave like um they gave you choices for uh for like what you can break and um included in the price was glass it was like um what is it called they're like basically like glass cups like glass beer bottles that you can throw against the wall the thing is i can't show you guys the room itself because then people would sort of know where it is uh so i can't really so i could like Like,
I could, like, basically get the, like, pick up the glass and just start chucking it at the wall or some shit.
Or, like, the other alternative is that, okay, let's see.
Is that they have these, which I find out how heavy crowbars are.
So this is this lovely selection of weapons that I got to pick from yesterday.
and i found out how fucking heavy uh crowbars are that day um so choose your web yeah that fat is fucked up yeah that's a fun like people were fucking angry i was asking the guy i was just like so like what the fuck do people do and they're like oh yeah no um because on the floor was just like a bunch of like broken thing items like because like it's just like a accumulation of everybody that was in the rage room um and so like he was like yeah like 30 minutes is like the limit in this room the maximum limit you can be in this room and he's like even when you like he's like oh yeah even when people broke all the things that they purchased they would just start smashing the items on the floor and just go ham and i was just like damn like this is definitely cheaper than therapy i was like
he was just like yeah no they just like they just started like standing in the pile of trash and just fucking start swinging and screaming while like uh hammering the trash and i'm like damn i fucking need that like i fucking need that so so i did pay extra for one thing because like um the glass beer bottles were like wasn't cool i also did like i also like smashed like you know i perched there was like uh there's like a little perch thing and i could put the glass bottle like the glass beer bottle um on top of this little perch thing and then like and then i could just um and i could just i used it as like a perch and just like play baseball and just smashed it with a crowbar i got a crowbar i was like oh i was like ah And like,
fucking just went ham on, like, and, like, smash that glass on the perch with a fucking crowbar and a baseball bat, too.
Not the fucked up one, the other, the bar one.
Like, hey, batter back.
Anyway, so, so I did that.
And there is, there is a Bluetooth speaker.
The guy was like, oh, yeah, if you want to play music or anything, you can link up your...
phone to this Bluetooth speaker.
But like at that point, I wasn't here for music.
I was not, I was not here for music.
So there was one item that I picked that I paid extra for.
It was only $20 because it was like, you know, I was just like $20 and $20.
And like there was one item that I picked that I was like, I'm gonna fucking go on town.
I was like, these glass bottles are not
Yeah, no, no music, just pure rage.
I was like, these glass bottles are not enough for me.
Like, the glass cups.
I need something more.
So, um, I got, I bought a giant ass monitor.
Like, it was $20.
And I bought it, like, a giant ass monitor.
And I got a crowbar.
And I was just like, oh!
I just started, I got the crowbar and just, Started fucking hammering it like yesterday was last week and yesterday was so much.
I fucking hate my bake
Yeah, so um look it was twenty dollars was twice like I said cheaper than therapy Um, um, so um, so I got the crowbar you could tell that it was a crowbar Like, because you can see the hole.
So I got a crowbar and just started fucking hammering the shit out of this bioner.
Yeah, it was like, like, roid rage.
So that was my day yesterday.
And now you see why I needed to take my nap today.
Like, I'm still recovering from yesterday.
I that day was the day I learned how fucking heavy crowbars are it was so heavy I was like Jesus Christ like this shit was heavy um um but yeah anyway patricia thank you for the super chat thank you thank you looking for a new monitor smash your old one in a fit of rage don't Super recommends the mpg 300 200 urx qdoled by msi check it out in the description of this video thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um but anyway Batman time oh I don't know how to segue this but Batman time time for Batman we're gonna finish it today all right let's let's boot up
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I needed it, though, guys.
I really needed it.
Yeah, I was thinking of myself as the Joker and that monitor as Jason Todd.
But this time, he ain't coming back.
That monitor ain't coming back.
How is the soundproofing in that raid trip?
Okay, the funny thing is that, like, um it wasn't just a rage room like facility they also had escape rooms as well so so i could hear the music and people trying to figure out how they escape while i'm smashing the items in that room i i could hear like the fucking music coming from one of the escape rooms next to me while i'm like So I'm like wondering,
do they hear like, like, I'm wondering, because like one of the escape room themes is like literally like, um, it's like a prison break or some shit.
And I'm like wondering, are they thinking it was just immersion where like I'm just a sound clip being played up in the background for it to make sure they're more immersed?
You know, that's what I'm like thinking.
you down in the escape room.
Keep that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Does it give like the ambience for them?
Oh my.
Okay.
Where am I supposed to do?
Breach Wonder.
What the fuck?
Oh wait.
Breach Wonder Tower to stop Pro.
Scan the Oh okay.
I got scan the helicopter.
I forgot about these helicopters.
I made business sense.
Yeah.
yeah I was gonna say like I'm just thinking like why like like what do are they thinking right now for a merchant we had an actual serial killer trying to get you in the next room over yeah I'm like do they think it's like like I'm just part of the room like part of the escape room
So you became Batman yesterday.
No, I'm the Batman that does kill.
Okay, it's not in there.
No, Batman's too much of a fucking pussy to finish the job.
There wouldn't be another joke.
There wouldn't, Joker would not be sending people at Super Aids if I'm there for the city.
Alright, scanning time.
Let me scan!
Oh my god, it's out of range.
Alright, how about you?
Already scanned?
God damn it.
Where would it be closer?
Is it you?
It's not you.
Wait, you can't, you'll shoot back?
I didn't know that.
Oh, I can grapple.
I forgot about that.
I can grapple on him.
What are you doing?
What are you looking at?
Get away!
No, you don't.
Nuh-uh.
Doki became Doki-tot.
Dang, I think it was a super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nuh-uh.
Stop!
This is not cool.
Don't make me go back to the rage room.
Don't make me go back.
I don't even know which one I'm scanning, which one I haven't scanned.
guys you know how much i um how i was so angry i didn't even look at how much how expensive the room was like i knew what i wanted price was not the question here
are you serious where the fuck is this plane
holy shit There's so many helicopters!
What the fuck is paying for all these helicopters?
Okay, but like, this was like, I didn't use my business card for it, unfortunately.
I...
I felt like it should have been a business expense for what I had to deal with.
I'm de-stressing from my work.
all right let's scan these helicopters oh my god bro there's so many like where are we getting this funding and yet they still beg me for money why are they still begging me for money
oh my god no you don't uh closing welcome to the tomato farm welcome Welcome.
If they can afford, maybe if they don't spend it on the 20th helicopter, Gotham City wouldn't have to be in debt all the time.
Oh my god.
There's no way I would fund for this.
Alright, let's figure this out.
I need to scan this one goddamn helicopter that's on top of me.
Oh my god, there you go.
Oh my god, we did it!
Get over here!
I found you!
Oh my god, I found him.
Alright, there you go.
Wee!
What do I do here?
Oh, download it.
Alright.
You wouldn't download a helicopter, would you?
I've got the code.
I'm heading to Wonder Tower.
Good.
You're doing the right thing.
The code should let you enter via the guardroom.
Don't lose Talia's signal.
When I'm finished in the tower, I'm going Greetings from Serbia.
Hello, so thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And hello.
I need to save her.
Alright.
I gained access to the Wonder Tower.
Okay, I gotta head here.
Alright.
Breach, gain access.
I already did.
I did the fucking thing, guys.
God, so needy.
You're so needy, Batgirl.
Oracle.
I'm already heading there.
All you gotta do is just sit on your ass.
I mean, like, to be fair, it's like, um...
To be fair, I will say it was out of your head.
Look, I am not...
I will admit it's not your fault that you had to sit on that you can't use your legs anymore I She can't do anything else Look I'm not saying I'm guys guys guys I'm not what's the word
You can't say that
Alright let's see we gotta go this way Yeah she's acting like she's got shot or something on like in her spine like god
guys this way
that's right no eyes on me because i'm batman whoa batman down what a killing joke
Get down!
Now where's your buddy, huh?
That's right.
Your buddy's down here!
Alright, nice.
Is this it?
Yeah, this is it.
Uh...
Alright, hack time.
Guys, don't cancel...
Don't cancel Bruce Wayne, guys.
You can't cancel...
You can't cancel Bruce Wayne?
He'll just buy his way out!
They'll just throw money at it and it'll disappear!
That's right.
All right, we have it this way.
Arkham City Processing Center.
Oh, I'll use all the things I learned, guys.
Okay, it's the other way.
I don't remember how to use the ice thing.
What is the ice?
How do I use the ice move?
okay wait guys how do I do the ice move when I chuck the grenade that's my special power of course it is oh wait there's a lot of people down there RT twice all right let me try that out first all right nice that's all I wanted to know oh that's not what what I oh it's okay I can climb plan that's That's all I wanted to do.
Wait, is it?
Yeah, that is.
Okay.
All right, there you go.
What the fuck?
Did I just go backwards?
Oh, no, no.
I'm supposed to go here.
Or is the political prisoner?
If you have tiger guards have stun sticks, I need to attack from behind to avoid being hit.
AAX.
Okay, AAX.
All right.
Whee!
Wait, why?
Okay, I was gonna say AAX AAX AAX Oh, okay, and then I should start punching.
I just realized Okay.
There we go.
Oh my god, I forgot how to play this game.
I didn't.
Guys, it's been a while.
It's been a while.
Okay.
Don't worry, whoa!
Alright, there you go.
You did it.
And then...
Takedown!
Stop right there, Batman.
We need to talk.
Oh, who's he?
I know you wouldn't be able to live with yourself if your actions were...
I don't even know who this guy is!
I have a question for you.
Before my arrival, this city was drowning under a time to fill.
Hey, guys, guys, I am listening to him right now.
This is a cutscene.
Guys, this is a cutscene.
I can't do anything about it.
Bro, I can't even walk.
I can only walk.
Guys, this is a cutscene.
You don't fight in a cutscene.
It's like how you don't interrupt the magical girl transforming.
It even exists if not for you.
It must be depressing.
All your sacrifices and yet, You are the one to blame.
I hate them.
I hate this.
This is beautiful.
We have a long...
They're breaking the sacred rule.
Soon, I will take my rightful place at my master's side.
There's more people coming in!
I'm still listening to this cutscene!
So thank you, Batman.
What the fuck?
For all your help.
Now, kill him.
Oh, now kill- oh, guys!
Guys, please!
Please!
I look how they're like, yeah, now we kill him as fuck.
That's actually fuck.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
There's so much.
Okay.
Oh my god.
God, there's so much.
Oh, my God, I didn't want to kill him.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, shit.
This is it.
I'm trying.
There's so many.
Okay.
Guys, you guys don't understand.
There's so many people here.
Okay.
Bro, okay, that's it.
Get out of here.
No guns.
Oh my god, there's more.
There's more.
Jesus Christ.
Guys, I don't think we're living this.
I...
Oh shit!
That they got 83 heads!
They all surrounded me in the cutscene.
I couldn't move!
You don't understand!
Guys, if I would, I would have moved.
You know it.
Oh my god, I got hit.
Guys, it was not a choice that I fucking...
I just stood there, planning to beat me up.
Like, I don't know if you guys know this.
It was definitely not a choice for that to happen.
There you go.
We're doing it.
Freeze!
Oh my god, I forgot about this.
There you go.
I'm back at my groove.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
Get out of here!
Bam!
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
Alright, nice.
That's right.
It's slam dunk.
Oh my god.
Okay, I did not expect.
I'm doing it.
Just keep pressing buttons.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Alright.
you.
Okay, I'm out of here.
That's it.
Freeze!
Oh no.
Oh no, this is bad.
This is bad.
Freeze!
Oh shit, this is so bad.
This is so bad.
Freeze!
Oh!
Okay, there you go.
Oh god.
There you go.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Freeze!
Whoa!
You can't get me!
Get me!
There you go.
We're five.
Freeze!
Okay.
I'll now beat him up.
Guys, I was 1 HP.
I got scared.
Alright, and then...
There you go.
Wait.
Come on.
That's right.
We'll finish you off.
Observe.
Take this.
No.
All right.
We gotta go do the thing.
Where do I go?
I guess the one locked door?
All right.
Tell you how much you appreciate Batman now you'll be a fan of me sorry are you enjoying the Batman club it's chaos in there strange is killing everyone he sent in here he calls it protocol 10 what do you want us to do wait here I'm going after strange wait oh wait strange is still talking oh wait he's not talking to me okay that's good because I wasn't paying attention out of there you want to join the Batman fan Club.
O-T-E.
We're in the prom now?
What?
Oh my god.
How the fuck do I get that?
Grappa?
Oh my god.
It was just for the Riddler.
Riddler!
How did he get here?
How the fuck did Riddler get here?
Where the fuck do I go?
Open door?
Oh hey, that's me.
Yeah?
Fucking knew that it was a mirror.
I mean, that was...
That wasn't part of the...
Anyway...
That's it?
Nothing here?
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
Riddle me this, Batman!
Did he just go through the front door just like that?
Okay.
All right.
How is he allowed to just go through the front door like that?
Okay, we gotta go all the way over there.
Okay.
Wee.
Now what?
Okay.
Not that.
Zoom is like...
Okay.
like yeah oh shit okay got a double line launch I see like a thing over there I assume I had to do this and then oh my god I made it I just made it yay okay all made it that was easy all right we go through this way it's like what this is I don't oh wait this is not the door what the fuck oh my god stupid goddamn okay stupid riddler okay we're not we're not doing your stupid riddles riddler you're in like a D a D character anyway you're D villain
Alright, there we go, and we made it.
Hello, Fiona.
It's you.
I told you I'd be back.
You're a D-List.
Yeah, he has an F at best.
This Joker's men came down here and started setting up camp.
I did what you said and hid, but...
What happened?
There were guards.
You know, the ones that work for Strange.
They came down and started killing everyone.
Just like that?
It was a bloodbath.
It sounds like Strange is trying to cover his tracks.
to be good at hiding doctor stay here and do it again i'll deal with the guards in that room you can just do that just murder people it's like they're villains or something oh that's oh i did that remember that pile oh my god it's still there hey my pile of bodies are still there that's crazy i was not expecting that what was that's the last one
What?
Oh my god.
Okay, this is bad.
This is bad.
This is very bad.
You think they lost me?
I don't think they see me.
No.
Oh!
Where's my smoke?
Whoa!
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry!
Serpentine!
Okay.
You don't know.
They don't know.
We are the future.
I told you they didn't know.
Oh shit!
Shoot this guy!
Okay, okay, okay.
We got a self-disk.
I got this.
Guys, guys, I figured it out.
Watch this.
Okay.
Okay, let me... Okay, this is, like, fucked up.
Um...
This is pretty fucked up.
Like, how the fuck do I self-disk?
Um...
Um... Are there even gates anywhere?
Like...
Wait, how the fuck do I self-disk?
Very insecure.
Tiger 43 to tell.
Oh my god.
This is all shit!
Get out of here.
Let me do this thing down first.
And then you can shoot me.
Okay, okay, I figured it out.
Oh my god, they know I'm here.
How?
Okay, watch this guys.
What?
Who looks down?
What the
fuck looks down?
That's fucked up.
That's right.
They don't go.
They don't know.
Okay, this is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
Switching to thermal.
Oh no, not thermal.
Oh no.
Not thermal.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's gonna be awkward for me.
But.
Wait, I have an idea.
Watch this.
Wait, he's gonna fucking put a grenade on there.
That's not fair.
That's not fair at all.
Okay.
Wait, do I get help for a trophy?
Wait.
You liars.
Okay, wait, watch this, though.
Watch this.
Okay, wait, I got...
Sorry, this was really hard.
Wait, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
There you go.
I had to slow down.
Okay, watch.
this guys we'll get there eventually poop there we go yeah we don't need stealth oh wait oh he got back up all right here you go you gotta drive by got your butt oh yeah yeah Coming over!
Whoa!
Just this one guy.
Oh shit, okay.
Don't worry, he's gonna get back up.
I'm coming over, buddy!
That's right!
Yeah, what you gonna do about it?
Poop!
Alright.
Here, I'm coming over again!
Here I come!
I have the perfect angle too.
I'm gonna end your bloodline right here!
Is he alive still?
There's no way!
Oh, here comes your play.
Are you still alive?
Don't worry.
It's not gonna stop.
Ah!
Yay!
Is he still alive?
Oh, he is.
Got your dick.
Oh my god, how long?
Okay, guys, I'm gonna go die now.
Guys, if anything, we are not clutching this with 1HB.
We are not clutching this with 1HB, guys.
I'm sorry.
I don't know how to tell you this.
I don't think it's gonna work.
He's taken out two of you.
Find him.
Alright.
It must have been like, what the fuck?
Whoa!
Oh, wait!
What the fuck?
Where did this guy come from?
It must have been the win, guys.
Like, how the fuck do I do this?
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Get down.
Get down, Batman!
As we move into the final stage of Protocol 10, I would like to congratulate all...
Oh, my God.
This is not fair.
is actually not fair as i look at the screens in front of me oh my god whoa what the
show that within three hours of city will be we're fine we're fine we're fine we're fine we're so fine by the end of the month in a metropolis we're so fine each modeled after arkansas should all be proud of you i got this guys we are the solutions we are the future
will work here what no you don't know you don't no you don't
no you don't Okay, okay, okay.
We'll figure this out guys.
It's been a week guys.
Have mercy.
It's been a week since I played
Whoa, oh shit.
Oh shit
Where do I smoke pellets?
Oh my god.
Give me a sec
What the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
Wait, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
Not here, not here, not yet, not yet.
That's not some idea yet.
Guys, it's not the idea.
This is not the idea.
But I have an idea.
I know how to do this.
Arkham City has become your tomb.
Guys, I have an idea.
I figured it out, guys.
Guys, I figured it out.
I got the idea.
Watch this, guys.
Call 10.
I would like to congratulate all Tiger forces on this wonderful achievement.
As I look at the screens in front of me, I can see that we are rapidly approaching the realities of
this.
Oh, shit.
You can just do that.
No!
Where did I go?
No?
Oh my god, he's not close enough.
There we go.
I'll get you close enough.
Oh!
Holy cheese, Batman.
I don't need this rough day.
I just need to slowly get over here.
It works.
That's right.
Let's get to my pilot.
Okay.
All right.
It's not camping, God.
Come on.
Get over here.
Come on, come on, buddy.
I need you to get over here, guys.
If it works, it works.
Hurry up.
That's some good-ass cheese, guys.
Oh, he's coming!
He's going- Oh, no, no, no, come on, buddy!
Come on!
What?
Wrong way!
Come on, wrong way, guys.
Yeah, I need you to be!
Oh, you gotta put explosives as if it fucking explosives are gonna help you fuck this
You know, I'm gonna get you Boos!
That's right
All right All right, let's see what he's getting closer Wait, wait, he's getting closer Come on, come on, a little bit closer Come on, yeah, come on Come on, you're almost
Guys, all right, I got my bait I got my bait guys, I got it I got the bait You're right.
Yes.
Bring them all here.
That's good.
Bring them here.
That's right.
Bring them.
Yes.
Get closer.
Oh.
Yeah, fuck.
I can kill them.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Carry up.
All right.
Target is moving this way.
Get closer.
That's right.
Your sniper friend can't help you now.
What the fuck?
That's right.
Get over here.
What's your sniper friend gonna do?
Nothing.
That's looking right.
Your sniper friends can only walk.
That's the only thing they can do.
But where is the sniper?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, you're trying to swap positions?
That's goddamn right.
Can't do shit now.
You gotta stay in location.
Gotta stay on your post.
Oh, yeah.
You're finally gonna move.
Look at.
Oh, little does he know?
He's the only casualty left.
Get in my fist!
I told you guys I'd figure it out.
I told you guys.
I told none of you believed me.
But I knew I would figure it out.
I knew I could figure it out.
Hellcast.
I knew it.
You all didn't believe me.
How do I get in here?
I hacked this?
It's already hacked.
All those bodies.
I thought it already hacked.
It's green, though.
What the fuck?
Okay, I did not see that.
Oh, I guess it's not hacked yet.
I thought it was hacked because it was green.
What our password could be, could it be?
Obsession?
We believe you would, could only do it with cheese.
Oh, well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's the only way.
It's the doki way.
Medication.
Doki plays the claw machine a very different way from the rest of us.
Papa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I knew playing it normally wasn't it.
Silly me.
When you trade your army against a professional vigilante and not against Turkey.
Absolutely.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, no.
Don't get, uh, don't get, uh, don't get him involved.
Don't get my butler involved in this.
What the fuck?
Bro, he doesn't get paid enough for this shit.
Back there.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, he's threatening Alfred.
Also, happy birthday, Factors.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear factor.
It's not control says that it's Batman No, it's not Locked and loaded open the doors Oh my god, what the what the?
Okay, I thought like you know when I said no, you know, they would believe me
Okay, okay, oh my god there was okay.
There was okay.
There we go.
Okay, there we go How was I supposed to to know what if it's one of us let's watch this i'm gonna wait till they reload i thought if i say no
that's right you regret that dude don't you
that's right freeze
i thought it would like you know to be fair i thought like more more of them would get like uh you know you would think like more of them got taken by the takedown in general that's right i'll do this first oh my god okay we got i gotta freeze you i gotta freeze the one with a gun get out of here no guns allowed get out oh shit Shit!
There's too many, too many!
One at a time!
Oh my god, you gotta get out of here.
Okay, bro.
Bro.
Give me a sec.
There you go.
I'll get him out of the way first.
Come on.
Oh my god.
God damn it.
I was trying to do that.
I'll try to get behind him.
Okay.
Buddy, I said no guns allowed.
Um, I made one thing clear and I said no guns allowed in this fight.
Get out of here.
There you go.
All right, we can get this guy out though.
Yeah, you like that?
Wait, I'll get you.
Actually, no, you.
All right, you.
You're easier.
That's right.
Killed all your friends.
Now what can I...
Wait, can I tag him?
Oh my god, dad, please.
Dad, I fed him.
Dad, please.
Freeze!
Okay, wait.
Okay, uh...
Ah...
You're so lucky.
I can't do the thing I wanted to do.
Let's see.
That's right.
That's hot.
We're bringing back electrotherapy.
It freeze.
All right.
What do I do here?
Bro, I can't even... Wait.
I think I can't even beat him up because he's on the floor.
Oh, no.
I played with my food too much.
There you go.
Get up.
I played with my food too much.
I gotta get you out now.
Alright, there you go.
You almost soft-locked my game.
Alright, what do I do now, Batman?
Reach to stop.
Wait, do I have to keep going up?
Am I not up yet?
I'm already up.
Oh, here.
Okay.
I was gonna say, there's a higher up?
Safeguarding.
There.
It says do not enter, which means I should enter.
Okay, okay, I got a little worried.
Okay, that was...
That was a little too close.
What's this?
Wait, what's this thing over here?
I don't know what this is.
Am I supposed to do anything with that?
Whatever.
Not that important, I think.
It looks cool though.
Anything here?
Wait, why is it green?
Can I break this?
Why are you green?
What?
Is this the Riddler juice?
Oh my god, is this related?
Oh my god, is this related to Riddling me this?
God damn, how are you here?
Oh my god, this is your father, Riddler.
This is his fault.
It's always his fault.
I'm supposed to electrocute it.
He's just everywhere.
Everywhere I look, I see him.
Am I not supposed to be here?
I don't know if I'm supposed to be here, guys.
I have the tower.
Up, then left?
I'll climb it again.
Go up and look at the tower.
The ledge.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm like, where's the ledge?
Keep going up.
The fuck is the ledge for this?
Oh my god.
The two pipes on the left.
Two pipes on the left?
Am I blind?
I'm blind.
I'm fucking blind.
I know I'm blind.
I'm blind.
There's no way.
I'm definitely blind right now.
I'm...
There's no way.
Go up, then look left.
Left.
Here?
There's no way.
Because this is where...
Oh, run the jump!
Oh my god, I'm blind.
I am actually blind.
Because it did not look like anything to me.
Okay.
Whoa!
Okay, there you go.
Guys, there...
I...
Okay, but to my defense, where is the yellow paint?
In my defense, yellow paint where can you can you really blame me how am I supposed to know this is clamble when it's up when it's all black huh I'm nearly at the top I'll stop him I'll get there eventually he's working with someone I intend to find out who the moment I stop protocol 10 that's right I'm gonna do it oh my god goddamn looking really real this Batman how did he climb up here he could have saved the world but instead he's out here putting trophies on things I can tell it I mean it's not as fun I will admit it's not That's fun.
Special combo whip trip.
Oh, wait.
That's just for it.
We don't need her.
Oh, wait.
That's all for her.
We don't need for Serena.
You don't need this shit.
Wait.
Oh, yeah.
We don't need that.
Let's get.
Oh, I don't know what to get.
What the heck?
Line launcher type, bro.
Okay, yeah.
I don't think we need any of that.
What do we get?
I'll grab this.
I'm just like, what is the Riddler doing here?
Alright, now we're inside.
Oh, wait.
No, we were inside before.
Now we're back here.
Wait, what?
Wait a minute.
Oh, here you go.
I have to look up.
Gamers don't look up.
Where could you be?
Screw.
I don't fucking know.
Master...
Mass...
Perf...
Mint...
Maiden!
Serial!
That's a word.
Alright.
You and they don't know I'm up here.
Because they don't look up as well.
Alright, I'm here.
Batman's here now.
Oh, up here.
Oh, that's a lot of people.
I think it's supposed to be out here, but...
I just want to enjoy the scenery just a little.
Oh, wait, maybe it is.
Oh, it is up here.
Alright, up I'll go.
I thought it was one-way.
In my defense, I thought it was a one-way window.
Unfortunately, it was not.
This is our finest moment.
That...
...to destroy everything that claims this city.
Okay, I have an idea.
But like...
It requires some maneuvering.
I don't know, maybe he freaky like that.
This is a glorious day.
Protocol 10 is in effect.
And soon...
No, uh-uh.
what how that's it i'm coming for you bro i'm gonna run through everyone that's right he can't get me i'm coming for you
okay okay in my defense i didn't realize he would lock himself i was gonna i was gonna run straight in here and punch him The door is locked.
I can't believe it.
My cat, I punched through it.
It's not fair.
I, to be fair, I thought I could punch through it.
I really did.
I really did think I could punch through that.
Oh my god, what the fuck do I do here?
Okay, wait.
unbeatable i have it plaid it'll work this time guys this plaid will work this time
trust me
this is a glorious day protocol 10 is that man will be dead
yeah Yeah.
Yeah.
He completely vanished.
Where could he have gone?
You know?
No?
No.
Couldn't be.
That's crazy.
Yeah, I gotta figure this out guys.
This is a little harder to cheese now.
Okay, what if they come over?
Okay, watch this.
He has to come out, right?
Come on.
Come on, you wanna go sightseeing?
Oh, oh my god, come on.
Come on, boy.
Come on.
You know you wanna look out the...
beautiful window and enjoy the lovely scenery come on boy that's right you like that's right oh you want to come over too you know you want to What the fuck?
What the fuck?
Oh, shit!
Can you just do that?
Okay, he doesn't know.
Yeah, just, yeah, right.
No, my gargoyle!
Oh my god, he broke it!
That's not it.
messed up.
No one breaks my gargoyle!
That's right!
Bam!
Oh, God.
There you go.
That's cheating!
That's my high ground!
A beautiful gargoyle!
Oh, my God!
That's messed up.
That's actually messed up.
Watch this.
Your friends don't know.
That's right.
Boom!
That's right!
Oh, your friends are dead!
Alright, we did it.
Can you hear me, Mr. Of course you can.
Broke your spy.
Yeah?
Now watch me slowly hack your thing.
He's like, you can't... Oh wait, wait a minute.
That's right.
Yeah, you're untouchable?
Gotham.
Saviour.
You have not won.
Wait, stop!
I have saved Gotham.
That's right.
You're untouchable.
Give me a sec.
Let me hack this real quick.
That's right, nerd.
Get back in the locker.
Also, what about Joker?
Are we forgetting the Joker's subplot here?
What happened to the Super 8?
Look at what you've done.
It's glorious, isn't it?
You're finished, Strange.
One problem at a time.
Look, we have a lot of problems in Gotham.
You cannot stop me.
Soon I will command forces beyond your comprehension.
I have achieved what the great Batman could never do what Gotham will forever thank what did you even achieve oh Talia oh wait Raz Agu your part of this is over professor strange why I did everything you wanted indeed don't worry he reincarnated into Marvel that man is better than you let him die detective he was your puppet rash why you said i could replace you this was our vision and you failed to see it through but when you came to me with batman's identity i gave you this chance to prove your worth providing you with limitless resources for your plan you came close failed me he's going to die rish he needs medical attention now i'm pretty sure that knife went through like several organs already i don't think it's saveable i don't think it's salvageable unless we put like duct tape over his lungs like that's a lot of blood this is a good day detective good people are dying the world will not miss them yeah i think you can survive that look at my work you may have he's like this is
my work now it's strange dr strange is like this is my work and then ralda was like this is my work now you've become what you've always fought against you made this i made this i doubt it computer activate protocol 11.
What are you doing?
Pass called Wayne.
Bro, what the fuck?
He used my name.
He's doxing me with his password.
Order 66.
God, he's so obsessed with me.
What the fuck?
What?
okay we'll just we'll just put him in that little crazy fountain what a good plan i noticed thank god you're all right it's okay we'll just when did we just cut up his body this whole place was and then he'll never be able to revive himself does that work that way if we cut up his body and like cremate his scar oh my god it's my it's the x guys it's my x something's Then the fountain can't bring him back.
I'm not caught you at a bad time, have I?
I was worried that you may have forgotten about little old me.
Take a look at your girlfriend.
Oh, as you can see, it's in danger of having your pretty little brain flattered all over this camera.
Ignore him, Bynid.
Let him die.
We could just put her in the fountain if she shoots her.
The only problem is, I've never felt better.
And we both know, you really can't ignore me, can you?
Okay, look, you're the one that called me eight times, Joker.
Like, it's over.
It's been two years, move on.
He wants me so bad.
Got get the cure and stop him okay follow the tracker to save Talia all right where's the tracker Where the okay I was gonna say where is it like we mean follow
He's so obsessed Repeat return to base immediately repeat return to base
What tracker Okay get the cure from batman and stop him from becoming immortal follow tracker to say where the there's no waypoint what waypoint oh there it is oh okay so i was looking at the compass i was like what are you talking about all right there you go okay to be fair i was like trying to find on the map in the compass But it was right in front of me the entire time.
Oh, God.
There's so many snipers.
I'm just going to.
Oh, my God.
What is this jigsaw?
Like, puzzle.
Oh, my God.
The snipers are covering the snipers.
Like, what is...
Oh, my God.
Fuck this.
Oh, God.
Oh,
shit.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
That's five.
Whoa!
Can't get me!
There you go.
Okay, this is bullshit, Joker.
Like, what is the sniper covering?
The sniper can't die.
The sniper has a sniper looking for the sniper and the sniper is looking for the sniper.
Oh my god, they're all covering each other!
That's right.
Don't got your gun now.
They got the full coverage.
That's got them right.
What you gotta do when you have no sniper?
Huh?
That was your entire plan.
Oh my god, he got the sniper back.
Oh my god, I'm 20 sniper rifles on me.
Alright, there we go.
Now you actually can't do anything.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Would he chuck a rock at me?
Bro, that's...
You're so lucky you can't...
You're so lucky.
That's it.
Oh, wait.
He just dodges that.
Joker, I don't know.
Why did you hire 80 snipers?
Okay.
You want me to get off this annoying woman, right?
Maybe if you didn't hire 80 snipers, everything would be fine.
Blah, blah, blah, mystical mumbo-chumbo.
I'll tell you what.
I'll do it.
But you owe me.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
There you go.
They had one for every call you missed.
Bro, they even...
Covering a door?
Who's covering the sniper?
Oh my god
Oh my god, this is actually bullshit.
There's a...
The sniper has his own sniper body guide who has his own sniper body guide who has its own... When does it end?
When does it all end?
Oh my god.
When do all this end?
Who is the last sniper?
I gotta disable the sniper ring from the outside.
I need to find the last sniper that doesn't have a body.
guy it has to be that guy all the way back there it's him we gotta start from the outside in it has to be that guy there's no way this has to be the last one oh wait unless it's him it might be him okay we gotta go starting from the outside first sniper covers the last sniper there's no way it can't all be snipers oh my god it can be it can be all sniper
oh my god oh my god batman please
okay jesus christ please whoops all sniper Okay,
we got three of them.
Where are you, Batman?
I got your premier ticket right here in my pocket.
It's right here.
Next to the gaffer tape and the pliers.
Alright.
Got another one.
Okay, now I can do a silent one right here.
Alright.
where's the next chain of where's the next chain of of command the next sniper chain of command right here okay we gotta start from here
oh my god i wanted to go up no how did it get here why are you taking so long batman oh hold on i get it you want me to Oh my god, no one's covering this way.
No one's covering him.
Oh my god.
Who was covering him?
Who was covering?
Oh!
I don't understand.
I thought no one was covering him.
That's right.
You don't have to.
I don't have a gun now.
I don't have to worry about you.
Oh my god, I need it.
Okay, this guy is just useless.
This ain't over.
It's no gun for you now.
Okay, right?
Get out of here.
There we go.
You don't also don't have a gun now.
You can't hear me, right?
You don't seem to be coming to the movie theater.
I'd hate for you to read the spoilers on the internet again.
There you go.
He can throw a rock.
What the fuck is a rock gonna do?
Alright.
There's him over here.
Bam!
Alright.
Bro, you have no guns.
Shut your...
your trap no yapping can't do shit bro you don't have a gun shut the fuck up you can't do shit
yeah is he what is he gonna do he's like who's that I like how his buddy's like he'll be fine What's keeping you?
Get your cute little ass in a movie theater.
Now!
That's right.
Get out of here!
Oh wait, I did not mean to do that, but it's fine.
Oh shit!
Watch this.
Boom!
There we go.
Take down!
Alright, now I can open the door.
what oh it was Paul guys it was Paul not push hurry up and take it see Batman the show about to begin let's just talk about this now you want to talk too late Batman Just find your shooter.
We'll just put it in the fountain.
I don't think that's the real joker anyway.
That's fine.
That's true.
I would never have killed him.
Yeah, no blood.
He had no bones, guys.
Where is his bones?
There's no way he was there.
I just wanted to see if I could do it.
You know, I told the doctor to take out a rib, but then he took out more than just the ribs.
How do you keep a secret from the world's greatest detective?
Will do you get right in front of them right on me?
Joker wants you to think he's sick.
Then wait, gotcha.
You know this wasn't a mirror.
Yeah, see?
Like, he didn't even turn around.
Oh.
I'm sorry, beloved.
I knew it wasn't a mirror.
I didn't know.
I knew it.
It has to be Clayface, isn't it?
It was a never-heat-all.
I told you.
I'm the world's greatest detective.
I'm Batman.
He's an actor.
It's important to keep up...
Oh yeah, I know the super-aids is getting to him right now.
Oh.
But first, if you would be so...
I think you might need some stronger makeup.
And over my...
He's classically trained!
Yeah, he don't sound so good.
Ladies and gentlemen, for one night of...
standing in for yours truly.
Why does Clayface...
I guess it's like a good role to play.
I give you...
I fucking knew it.
It was so obvious.
I was like, where are his bones?
Why sign up with Joker?
Easy.
The role of a...
I knew it!
Yeah, see how it's gonna stay?
Like, why would... who would ever turn away from this role?
It's a great acting role.
You could get an Oscar.
He could get an E-GOT, you know?
The final act's just starting.
It's a doozy.
Bro, he's getting his E-GOT.
Oh!
my god how how do I what okay
I can I can throw this forever clay face oh my god maybe not bro he'll get his egot I believe that's right oh shit I was gonna say get dark souls All right.
Okay.
Oh, well, okay.
He goes doing again.
Oh, nice.
It's literally Dr. Sos.
Oh, my God.
Nobody expects that.
All right.
We're halfway there.
It's fine.
All right.
You wouldn't expect him to be slowing down after it, too.
Because that, you know.
He's mud.
He's literally made of clay.
Alright.
Nice.
I'll wait for him to come back up.
Whoa!
So close.
No!
Alright.
Dodge!
One more hit.
Nice.
Don't you stand around?
No E got for you.
That's right.
Slashy, slashy!
Get out of here!
Wait, what?
Wait, there's more?
Phase two?
What do you mean, phase two?
Oh, no.
Wait, he gets his HP back.
I don't.
It's not fair.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I didn't realize he was gonna...
Oh, my God.
I didn't realize there was a phase two.
Oh, this is bad.
I was poking around.
I was definitely not trying too hard.
Oh, this is bad.
Guys, I don't know.
I was not expecting a phase two, guys.
Oh, Batman's not doing so good.
Okay.
Okay, he rose twice now.
Oh, shit, wait.
That works.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That does not work.
Wait!
I...
This was the performance!
Okay, okay, okay.
I didn't realize there were ever others to it.
Okay, this is...
It's fine.
We got full-age.
We died tactically.
Look, I didn't think...
I was not expecting the second hit.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Yeah, the second hit fucks with me.
I don't know if he can dodge that.
He dodged that second hit?
Because it didn't look like I can.
Thank god there's a checkpoint.
Yeah, okay, I have to...
Oh, I have to crouch!
Okay, that makes sense.
Sorry, it's too big.
I've been too busy fucking Just spam rolling.
Okay.
Wait, I could tank this
Yeah He's one hit There you go I freeze don't just stand around I was like get over here all
right savvy savvy oh my god okay yeah fully savvy don't worry he's made up clay so technically i'm not killing for my spa treatment i mean it's not like you've got a girl to save anymore is it oh no it's okay i have the fountain too soon would a change of scenery help ease the pain my ex got jealous of my other
Where's Catwoman?
Oh, there's the fountain.
I just need to put Talia in here and she'll be fine.
A little crazy, but like, Batman likes that, apparently.
Batman is okay with a little crazy.
Okay.
I think Batman only dates crazy.
Honestly, I don't think he dates like a normal woman.
I don't think he's ever dated a normal person.
Yeah, the crazier, the better, exactly.
He's not here about stability.
He has the...
He's so obsessed with being like, I can fix her.
Because he can't fix himself.
He's like, if I can't fix myself, I can fix her.
Which is not very healthy, but I don't think a man in a bat suit is healthy in general.
Jesus Christ, they're just slapping me.
Like, don't worry.
Jesus.
Bro!
Yeah.
Got his stupid little minions.
I'm literally killing his little baby.
Come on.
There we go.
Things he'll do for an Oscar.
Oh my god, Batman!
What the fuck?
I know you're freaky, but not that freaky.
Yeah, you gotta match that freak.
Warming my Batman?
I should be okay now.
I'm cured from Super Aids.
Get out of my way, bats!
I've got a date with immortality!
Oh!
Oh shit!
Oh no, wait, Clayface?
Wait, does it work with Clayface?
I don't know if giving Clayface immortality was a better alternative.
Quick!
The cure.
What are you waiting for?
Yeah, I can use it on Talia, too.
Your girlfriend.
Poison, Gotham, and hell.
Yeah, but he could be double immortal.
But so what?
We all know you'll save me.
Every decision you've ever made ends with death and misery.
People die.
I stop you.
Yeah, but he can be double immortal, guys.
Do it again.
He could be immortal, Whoa, shit!
Bro, you fucking idiot, Joker!
Boy, it's okay, you can lick the floor.
Oh, no, Joker.
That's sad.
Oh, Joker.
You.
That is so sad.
Bro, what do you mean, am I happy?
You fucking sad me!
Bro, he's like, like the bicycle meme in sticks like how dare you batman he sticks a stick on his own bicycle
that's actually pretty funny
why would batman do this
oh at least he died happy
I don't get it.
Can you just keep licking the floor?
Aww.
His super aids was too strong.
Is he okay?
I guess you think he's okay.
Oh, that's so romantic.
You got princess carried.
What the hell happened in there?
Yeah, but...
The thing is with Joker dying, it leaves a power vacuum in Gotham.
That's the issue.
Now that all the villains know that Joker is dead, they're like, I'll be the next king of...
King of Gotham.
It'll be fine, right?
It'll be fine.
Absolutely, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He died as lived out junklered by jokey thank you for the super chat thank you thank you that was fun i really enjoyed um arkham city they definitely improved a lot with um arkham asylum with all the tools and um also better thank you for the five gift and ships thank you thank you yeah they definitely improved a lot with the uh with all the tools that uh upgrades and stuff and i love exploring How long is the DLC,
though?
Chat.
How long?
I gots enough.
If I do do the DLC, how long is the DLC?
What's the order?
What's the order of the Arkham series?
One hour?
Okay, if it's one hour, we can do it right away.
Arkham Origins or Nightnecks.
What should be the order?
seem short yeah we could do it next i mean we've only been streaming for two hours so it should be fine um sigil thank you for 10 gift of ships thank you thank you marcia thank you for super chat thank you thank you the way he holds joker is a reference to the painting of cane holding his brother's body it's not princess carry even though it would be funny thank you the super chat marcia thank you thank you it could be both though it could be both um but yeah no i think I what happened to cat woman she just this is why I was like what's the point of giving me cat woman upgrades if you only play her like two times I was like why the fuck would I waste my upgrades on her she's only there for two fucking sections like bitch I'm not giving you shit you can get things done with being deeper like oh now after I beat the game I can play oh my god Please,
I swear to God, if this is my ex, you're dead.
You cannot do this to me.
Oh, he had to have one last laugh.
He had to give me one last trauma for the ride.
Don't worry, all my Batman streams have been hit by copyright.
Oh, my God.
How are you still so obsessed with me?
You're dead.
How do you leave one final voice message?
It's the most toxic of toxic yaoi.
Origins is December.
You want to start it next month?
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Only me.
He is dead, but I know, like, Bruce is haunted by the death of his axe.
Because he was, like, the one that got away, you know?
He's like, no one could ever compare to you, Joker.
All of these women.
I try to replace you with all of these women.
But they'll never be compared to you.
He closes his eyes and he still thinks about the Junkler.
It's true.
Like, literally, he's singing a love song to me, chat.
He's literally fucking singing a love song.
Golden Foxy, think of a super chat, think of a thing.
short but it depends on how good you do on the final bus okay it's all okay how much stealth is the dlc also is there an is there a secret end is there a after credit scene chat oh hey nvidia
one stealth section is there an after credit scene yeah okay we gotta wait then marshall they even super chat they could thank you no woman can be as crazy as joker and that's
He was the ultimate I can fix her.
No one can.
He always chases that high.
He's been chasing that high since the Joker died.
He's like, if only I can fix you, like I can fix the Joker.
Did we skip this?
Oh, you can skip the credits now?
Okay.
I'll turn it.
Alternative Batman outfits.
Time to get my things and quit this damn town for good.
Wait, is this a DLC?
Wait, am I in it?
Did it just put me in it now?
Wait, am I in the DLC already?
Is this it?
Oh, okay, it added me right there.
Alright.
Then what's this part?
Why do I have to retrieve and...
Oh, I have to leave.
Okay, let her leave first.
Alright, we're gonna leave Arkham City and move to Metropolis, I guess.
This is still the main game?
Oh, it's short.
Okay.
Alright.
We're gonna go move to Metropolis after I get her loot.
Shit, my hideout is right here.
Remember how to live, how...
Where's my house?
Oh, there it is.
Home sweet home.
No!
I've been found!
Wait, my cats are in there.
What the fuck?
Who the fuck killed my...
My cats are in there!
Oh, shit.
Wait, this is not good.
Hang on.
She's waking up.
Damn it.
What are we gonna do?
Kill her again.
Excuse me?
Um, no, you do not.
No, you do not.
This is for my cats.
Bitch.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
I'll just keep hitting.
Okay, maybe I should have given you some upgrades.
I feel like you have, like, you're so weak right now.
I definitely should have given you some upgrades.
Oh, my God.
You have no HP, too.
I forgot about that.
I can't even...
Bro, I can't even do, like, finishers because there's so many people here.
Like, bro, he just slapped me.
He's like, I can't let my bro...
If I can't have a good time, you can't have a good time.
Yeah, I can't do finishers on them.
That's like, Watch out, watch out!
Okay.
Where are my things?
Yeah.
I think...
I think Arkham Catwoman has to have the best Catwoman design.
Arkham Catwoman is the best design-wise of the outfit.
Oh well.
Time for this kitten to teach you some manners.
Once and for all.
Because like, before then, Catwoman didn't look like that.
Catwoman didn't have this out like before then catwoman didn't look like that I remember and then like after Arkham after Arkham they they changed Serena into like this outfit as the main outfit No before before they did this outfit for Arkham it was a different it was like more like the more like the what was it the the movie catwoman outfit
Here?
Where is this?
Oh, it's here.
No, it's not!
Whoa!
Time to climb up!
Yeah, with Halbury.
Yeah.
Yeah, because I remembered, like, it was because of Arkham that everyone now associates uh catwoman's outfit like this now
it's like how what was it the new what what movie was it the suicide squad for uh uh for harley quinn i don't like i i'm so sad about that you know like the new modern the new harley quinn outfit because of suicide squad ever since suicide squad like the harley Quinn's outfit is is that outfit now like in every adaptation and that's I don't know I think it sucks it's a cat woman because like it's a good outfit but I do miss the classic Harley like the Harley Quinn outfit it is a good outfit I just do miss like you know the clown aesthetic versus like the ice cream how
the fuck do I get there oh it's up here
My HP is not doing so well.
Catwoman's here!
Eh.
They were like chilling.
They were just chilling with the homies.
I liked how they were all just hanging out.
I just came over here.
God, I wish your finishers were a little faster though.
Don't worry, he's not gonna throw this, right?
Yeah,
it's just, no, it's like pigtails, Harley Quinn now.
Open door.
Do I have the XP to lower up?
God, I hope so.
I don't think I do.
Yeah I don't.
I used it all up on.
Yeah, I know I don't.
Where's her loot?
I don't know.
I thought I knew was here.
Call it two faces, other face, dokey girl, or bird woman.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, man.
Wait.
Where do I go?
I had to go here.
Not here?
How come...
Where's my...
Where's my exclamation point?
Oh, I have to explore.
I was gonna say.
Where the fuck is my exclamation point?
Oh, I like my non-bat vision.
Just casually walk up.
Just casually walk up and be like, hey guys.
I don't know what I'm supposed to do here.
Oh, there you go.
Pounce attack.
I mean, you just throw this?
Do you think they'll know if I throw this?
Whoa!
There you go.
That works, too.
That works.
Bam!
Oh, shit.
Bro, you punched a lady?
Ladies, first!
Oh, my God.
My HP is not good.
My HP is not good right now.
Okay, there you go.
I just gotta make sure I...
Oh my god, this is not good.
Thank you.
I made it.
I know he's like getting his shit beat up, but he's like, bro, nice outfit, bro.
Agreed.
At least they agree to have a kick-ass outfit.
Oh, he's still in here?
What the hell are you supposed to be?
Okay, if you insist.
Oh, I forgot to say.
Speak to me like that again.
Yeah, he fit checked me.
He's like, bro, I might be a goon, but...
Bird to be torn apart by a cat.
I- I'm here to- I know when it's a good fit.
That's much nicer.
See?
You can be nice, Oswald.
See you around.
He's got an eye for fashion.
Yeah.
I guess I'll just keep going.
Oh my god, that's a lot of people.
I don't know if I can.
Yeah, don't think I've ever seen the boss so happy.
What the hell is she doing here?
My I'm not supposed to self that right Okay, hey guys
Yeah, no shit.
I'm scared I was like okay in my like I even supposed to be here
Okay, we're gonna figure this out.
I have to fight all of them?
Okay, this is fucked up.
Okay, it's fine.
I got whip, whip, whip, whip, whip!
There you go.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, look at all these combos.
Oh my god, that was like combo for days though
Okay, that was insane combo How do I still not have XP after that?
Come on, I pressed wide, bro
Okay, come on, get out of here Alright
Oh my god, I'm still going I'm still going I'm still going Jesus Christ Okay As long as I keep whipping Watch me whip
Watch me day day Bro I killed so many And I touched my toe and I fucking got a heart attack or some shit Oh that's awkward Give me a sec guys Now I'm ready for a fight That was a little awkward.
But it's okay.
I'm okay now.
Okay, it's fine.
13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23.
Oh my god.
Kicks for days.
Actually, kicks for days.
Oh my god.
This guy ruined my fucking combo.
God damn.
I had some.
That's a sick-ass combo, too.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I should have upgraded Catwoman.
I should have...
Guys, I definitely should have upgraded Catwoman.
How the fuck was I supposed to know she had this goddamn storyline?
I gave her nothing.
I didn't feed her.
Oh, my God.
I did not expect that.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
There we go, last guy.
Oh, not last guy.
Alright, last guy.
Watch me whip.
That's right, watch me whip!
That's right!
I'm a woman.
Listen to me.
That's right, give me your lunch money.
Hachat!
You know what?
Full ass!
Okay.
It's not there.
This is a dev's reward for not leveling up cat women during this story.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How the fuck was I supposed to know that?
Why do I get out of here?
Bro, they have shockwaves.
Wait, how do I open this?
I'm just a cat.
Oh.
Like, oh, it's here.
Okay, I stood through here.
Wait, I could have just...
Oh, my God.
I could have just ran away from this, guys.
I didn't even have to fight this.
I literally could have just ran away.
I can't believe it.
I got baited.
I could have just ran away.
Yeah, but this is cool.
Yeah, but at least you get XP, Doki.
Doki spamming low-kick, master gamer.
Thank you for the super chat, Kweezy.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, R-T-A?
Oh, okay.
Wait, how am I even supposed to get anywhere here?
Oh, yeah, never mind.
Never mind.
I don't know.
I assume, like, I don't know.
I thought it was ice for some reason.
What the fuck?
Anywhere I can crawl?
Climb the ceiling?
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
Really need this?
Batman.
Yeah, about that.
I wonder how my boots work for this.
Like, I understand, because, like, I don't actually, like, I guess my special power is that I have cat powers, but, like, um, cat, I I don't know.
From what I remembered, I don't think cats can crawl on ceilings, but I'm not sure.
I don't own a cat.
Any cat owners can fact-check for me, guys?
I don't know, I don't own a cat.
But maybe it's because I don't own a cat, so I've never seen a cat crawl on the ceiling before.
Oh, yeah, cats can do it.
Oh, I knew.
Yeah, cats can do it.
Hello.
There you go.
gonna hurt yeah i just come in crawling on all fours like a freaking freak yeah catwoman got bitten by radioactive cat that's true that's true i think i was like hey guys i'm just be a little freaky freaky on main oh there's two face oh she'll dare come back here she'll come straight back
Oh, Shazp, who's this?
I'm looking forward to it, sir.
Good.
This is our chance for glory.
Word is Joker's dead.
We all saw what happened to the rut that used to run this place.
Whoa, what happened?
Yeah, see the power vacuum.
We are the future of Gotham.
That's what I'm saying.
It's the power vacuum.
You dare stand up to us.
I think I know he sees me.
Or if I just slowly.
Yeah?
like you stupid oh shit no wait i wonder i was trying to prove okay okay okay but like i almost killed them though i i felt like i i was this close guys it was so close it was almost there i wouldn't look all i'm saying was that i was this close I thought I could get it out get away with it
It kind of worked
Word is Joker's dead.
We all saw what happened to the run that used to run this place We are the future of Arkham we are the future of Gotham No one will dare stand up to us, because if they do, we'll cut them in two.
I'm gonna do it again.
He's gonna come over.
No,
no, no, no.
We kill- we- we get him first.
Come on.
Come on, you know you wanna.
Oh, shit!
He's like, help me!
Oh my god!
Wait, that's not fair!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, Somersault!
That's right.
Still lost her.
Oh, shit!
Bro, bro, bro!
No, I'm not.
Oh, shit!
Quickly!
She's slowly somersaulting away.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got this.
I got this, guys.
Okay, I have an idea, guys.
I have an idea.
I know what to do.
Guys, I have an idea.
I'm looking forward to it.
So what I do?
Watch this, watch this, watch this.
This is our chance for glory.
Word is Joker's...
Oh my god.
There you go.
And then...
Okay, we get him out of here.
Get him!
Yeah!
That's it!
I told you!
You just gotta quick smash it.
Now tell me where you've hidden the rest of my stuff or I'll even out the other side of your face.
Look at it.
It's that easy.
I don't know.
I don't need no upgrades.
It worked.
Enough with the twos already.
Damn.
My nuclear punches.
It just keeps getting you into trouble.
I told you guys.
I told you it works.
I just had to...
I just had to not be silent.
I just gotta do like the fucking brute force.
The boom.
Oh hey Batman.
Just couldn't keep away, huh?
Yeah.
You can't say I blame you.
There's still work to do here in Arkham City.
Good luck with that.
Some enterprising individuals decided to help themselves to my things.
I intend to get it all back.
Now I'm his rebound.
He lost Joker and now he's like, you're what?
He's like, you are.
up you up girl oh this is where i swap oh i did was that it was that the story ends here all right i guess it's dlc time how do i get to the dlc oh no no there's a menu yeah yeah all right dlc time uh story synopsis where is the dlc Harley Quinn is this one is it is it Harley Quinn's revenge oh is it what's this oh is this costume challenges custom challenges wait there's nightwing where the fuck oh my god there's animated nightwing wait excuse me okay oh my god no that's what I'm saying before before Arkham these were
Oh my god, wait, I should have...
Are you kidding me?
I could have been playing as animated Batman this entire time.
Oh my god, there's old Batman.
Wait, which one is this Batman?
Oh my god, I could...
I could have been Adam West Batman this entire time.
Wait, okay, okay.
I didn't know I could be Adam West Batman.
Oh my god, they had Nightwing.
Damn.
him west okay
there you go let's start over from the beginning and now is
this a dlc i'm in any news barb this is not my animator robin you've been gone two days i'm worried you know what he's been like since i'll find him i hope you're right harley quinn's preparing for some kind of siege what she planning we start the whole playthrough don't worry barb it's me remember you sound just like him
oh they became harley goons you left me to die you left me to die you left me to die I don't think...
Yeah, I think Robin kills, guys.
This is not my animator, Robin.
There you go.
I have, like, the same moveset.
That's crazy that they were...
That Harley Quinn was able to get outfits so soon for everyone after Joker's dead.
Bro, bro, who's your...
Who's your manufacturer?
Harley Quinn was like, Alright, guys.
Here's your new uniform.
yeah it's the the robin that everyone forgets okay i want to be give me my can i not change my outfit no i can't play use the new outfit in in the dlc
and she paused no
oh that's crazy harley quinn works fast you already got uniforms for all the goons.
Alright.
No, apparently it doesn't work for DLC.
It's only new game plus.
Alright, sock kick versus sock kick.
Quinn's got him.
Negative.
I'm gonna keep looking.
Harley's telling the cops she's got some sort of plan for them.
They'll be safe for now.
Be careful.
This will end okay.
I promise.
Bro, there were since he lost his exes.
Like, Catwoman's right there, bro.
That's fun.
Oh, I have stuff.
Cheruk?
Cherkin.
Zip kit.
Bullet shoot.
Snap flash.
What the fuck is this, that?
What's a snap flash?
Is it, like, Flashbang?
bitch you blind forever temporary temporary blind bitch you blind forever sorry that's such a good quote I'm sorry I love that quote no it's like all over my timeline like that shit was all over my timeline you better get over the boss soon she's turning into a liability and what you thinking of taking over Wait,
what?
Okay, I thought...
I was like, wait, why can't I do the thing?
Wait, I can...
What's that?
What do you mean, temporary blind?
Bitch, you're not blind forever.
That's such... I don't know.
The way she said that is so good.
But it's like...
It's like my new brain worm right now.
Like, what's that word where it's like a quote that's always in your head?
It's like my new vocal tick.
Is that what it's called?
Also, my chat died.
It's like, Tyler.
It's so good.
Yeah, vocal stim.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the new vocal stim.
I can't hack things.
I'm not smart enough.
How do I do this?
Oh.
Yeah, thank you, welcome to the channel.
Manifan welcome welcome just saw you on the Marvel rivals oh did they announce it who would have expected that I feel like every time I'm like a secret sponsor can announce it and everyone knows it's rivals oh my god bro okay I have to talk about this but I saw on the rivals leak Twitter they're like because like last week they're like saying like oh my god when is the trailer dropping like oh it's not gonna be this week because and they you Okay,
it's so funny.
Okay, rival leak twitters now use me as a point of reference as to when we get our preview stream.
Because I saw one of those rival leaks Twitter accounts that was like, guys, I don't think we're gonna get the streamer previews this week.
I don't think the trailer is dropping this week because Jokey Bird didn't put anything on her schedule for a special sponsor.
Because obviously, Because I'm the only VTBird that has like pre-scheduled streams.
So they're like, Jokey Bird didn't put anything on her sponsors this week.
So I guess I don't think we're getting our trailer this week or like the stream.
Because I'm the only one.
I'm the only one that like has scheduled streams.
So they're like, guys, I don't think so.
She's like, look, she doesn't schedule anything.
Like, I'm like the source for when, Sarissa when like the leaks have like the the street the previews happen just kill all of us and some crazy revenge how do I use the fucking snap flash that man's little helper come I did it give me a sec I'm trying to figure it out I'm trying to blind you forever it's not even a leak it says special stream it won't let me throw I'm trying I am it doesn't let me throw it I'm sad bro I'm shut the fuck up try and figure this out don't make me throw this that's oh my guy.
Oh, I placed it on their back.
Oh, I don't want to get over there.
I'm trying to figure out to get over here.
Oh, LTMB.
I don't have it.
I just have Zipkick.
Oh, is there a vent?
Oh, don't worry.
I'll get over here.
Bro, Robin has like baby gear.
Batman doesn't trust him with the little zip line.
Oh, spider.
It's gross.
All right, give me a sec.
What's wrong?
Too scared to fight?
Yeah.
There we go.
I'm gonna blind you forever.
What the fuck?
What is this?
Wait, it didn't work.
Why didn't it work?
Oh, there we go.
Yay!
I blotted you!
Oh, shit.
Bro, I was about to, like, fucking stab him in the back or some shit.
How come it tells me to do, like, why shit?
Okay.
All right, I think Tim is like pretty strong because like Tim seems pretty strong because he has a fucking stick instead of a instead of his hands Oh, Y plus B Oh, I have to have a high combo I see
What oh
Guys the shield oh oh Oh, oh, oh guys I thought go up to the shield Go up to the gun and then like Smack it.
I didn't realize there was A hole I wanted to smack it Can I do this?
Wait, I made it.
I mean It worked.
No, please You don't understand No, really
That's right right I'm slowly walking over oh you're so scared what you gonna do oh you fucked up bro you fucked up you fucked up buddy that's right
BAM that's right you messed up huh yeah
that's right snipers can't do shit how do you What?
Okay, come on.
It didn't give me a little self-takedown.
Come on.
I deserve a self-takedown right there.
Okay, I think I can.
Oh, that sucks.
Why is so much armor?
I think I...
Oh yeah, I get, like, Batman's upgrades too.
Wait, I can shield bash?
I was like, where is my self-takedown?
Where do I go, too?
Up here?
I can't do shit.
I don't have anything.
Where do I go?
Old shield and then RT?
Oh!
I see it.
Here?
What is up here?
Huh.
There's nothing important.
The door?
Is that openable?
Oh, it was.
Oh, no, it's not.
Yeah, they welded this.
I was gonna say, are you straight?
I'm thinking they welded that door shut.
Oh, I guess there was this door.
Oh, there's this door.
Okay.
What the fuck were they guarding that door?
Oh, hey, guys.
Pick it up.
No way, man.
That thing's dangerous.
You saw what it did.
What did it do?
No, it's Batman's belt.
So what?
It's still just a belt.
Can you see me?
Why?
You afraid of a little electric shock?
Watch this, guys.
He's screwing with you.
What?
Oh, I chose the one person that can't be.
Okay.
I...
Really?
I actually, I chose the one person that can't be, okay, that's, that's so unlucky.
That's, how is I, guys, how, how was I supposed to know that the one person I chose?
That's crazy.
No way.
Oh my god, I can't see shit.
The one guy I chose cannot be, cannot do a takedown.
That's insane.
How unlucky am I?
Alright, that's fine.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
That's right, now you can't see forever.
Oh my god.
Time to pay a hospital bill, too.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, we're gonna grab you out of here.
Jesus!
Oh my god, that's a concussion right there.
I miss.
I do miss the ice grenade, though.
Okay, that's right.
That's it.
Get out.
This is what's it.
This was a 1v1.
No, I do love it.
I told you guys, this is my new vocal stem.
It's just the way she said it.
It's just so good.
The way she said it.
out of ten i have no idea anything about dispatch like but just that that clip in general
hmm she temporarily paralyzed me fuck you mean temporarily did you bear last forever
yeah that scene alone made me was like yeah i gotta play dispatch how'd you guess her goons ambush my guys and drag them towards the steel mill we can't get close i'll handle it you should sure you know she blames you right could be a trap fall back and stop anyone else getting hurt i'll handle the rest oh yeah i found out that like charlie voices the the batman the batman but the bad guy don't it wasn't your the new um the new um tumblr furry boyfriend
the man bat sorry the man bat am i supposed to go here?
Yeah, everyone's like super everyone's like super obsessed with the everyone's super obsessed with the man-bat guy.
That's voiced by Charlie.
You know how like so every year they nominate every year they nominate like furry of the year.
Furry husbando of the year.
and it's between the man bat and uh and one of the the dog guys i don't remember the dog guys from a new anime or some shit yeah have you guys not seen it okay wait okay this is very important i know like i shouldn't no you don't understand this is very important okay um every year twitter twitter oh here you go you'll understand when you see the list guys you'll understand every year twitter twitter slash tumblr nominates the furry boyfriend of the year so we got obviously we got zutopia man the while the the guy from the wild i don't remember the forest game him from eric agrisuko beast stars i forgot who this guy was bad guys,
Elden Ring, Z every year.
So, so now, now we have two five lists for 2025 and the thing is people are like, stop, please don't vote for that other, that wolf guy.
I don't remember, I don't even know who's, okay.
I don't remember who the 2025 nominee was, um, the wolf guy for the 2025 one.
But one of them is a wolf guy from the new i know like bow fucking screamed about it like on twitter i don't everyone's like please vote for mad bat break the wolf chain break them the
break the wolf chain no diversity we need diversity yeah We gotta break the pattern.
We gotta break the streak.
So, so everyone was like, we gotta vote for Man Bat to be furry boyfriend of the year.
Freelies break it.
It's been too long.
We have to end the cycle.
We gotta end the cycle.
He's gonna start dating again.
Bats aside, he needs this win.
Look, if the other guy, if everyone else votes against the wolf, we can win.
We can topple the wolf's supremacies.
Down here?
We can end the cycle.
Oh, there he is.
there's one of the cops oh how these cops are worthless sure we don't need to do this but that won't stop us do you realize how hard it is being a henchman listening to orders from a crazy person following them without questions there's this good retirement funds they have been to by that crazy woman exactly it's Not hard,
like sitting on your ass eating donuts.
That must be real.
Cinnamon roll must fall apart too.
Papa Smurf thinking it was Super Chat thinking, thank you.
It was gonna be pin the tail of the dead cop, but then we had a better idea.
Pin yada time!
Oh shit.
God no.
Help!
I wanna see what you've got inside you.
And if it ain't candy, I'm gonna be real.
Bro, this is their own rage room.
Help!
Is he actually beat him up?
That's great.
That's great actually.
Someone should help that man.
Man, someone should really help him.
Okay, nice.
I don't have HP.
Oh, I can never die.
I don't have HP, guys.
I just noticed that.
It's fine.
Can't kill me if I don't die.
Don't have HP.
Okay.
Oh wait, no, I got HP back.
Never mind.
It showed up.
God damn it.
I thought I didn't have to worry about HP.
Okay, yeah.
About making sure that he doesn't get his...
Gotta make sure he doesn't get his gun.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
As long as the guy with the gun is frozen, No one can have a gun.
Come on, get over here.
Get over here.
Boop.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, I can't choke him out.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say, I got, he has, like, the extra armor, so he won't let me choke him.
All right, get down here.
Come on, jump down.
Bro, just jump down, bro.
Why are you so scared?
What are you waiting for?
Get me down.
Bro, you can literally jump down.
It's not even that high.
Just jump down.
Why are you scared of?
You're literally a cop.
You're trained for this.
You have the legs.
You're safe.
Am I glad to see you?
Oh, God, bro, he's not looking so good.
Where are the others?
We were ambushed.
outside the steel mill and beat the crap out of us.
Yeah, you ain't looking so good.
These bastards dragged off the others and brought me here.
I'll find them.
Wait here.
Hide.
Alright.
Alright, we gotta this way.
No problem.
I'll just be waiting here.
I already did my job.
I saved you.
Okay, wait, where'd I have to go?
Okay, I gotta investigate the steel mill.
Oh, it's locked.
Was I not just here?
Go up.
That's gonna sit.
Like, I thought I was just there.
Oh, there's a baby that she never had.
Aw.
I'm talking to Commissioner Gordon of the GCPD.
What were they discussing?
We're hearing reports that a number of police officers are missing.
Oh.
Wait, is that negative?
Wait, that means negative, right?
I thought that was positive.
Yeah, it says negative now.
Oh, was she like, oh.
Did you guys know?
Okay, fun fact.
You know, like, I think this was like, is it Drake?
Fun fact, but like, so you know how like some...
Jesus, that's a lot of pregnancy tests.
Oh my God, that is a lot.
Bro, that's a lot of pee.
That...
That is a lot of pee.
Anyway, fun fact.
But...
so you know some celebrities they'll hook up with like you know random women like you know like at the party or instagram women well it's instagram women for some reason but uh but like uh so like you know the thing about it is that a lot of them want to baby trap the celebrities you know so uh so like a lot of them try to baby trap the celebrities because you know they can get child support off of them or like you know therefore you know you can force them to marry you and stuff because you know you have a baby so um so like drake apparently what drake does is that after he's done he's done he like um instead of throwing away the condom he would put um he would put like uh hot pepper sauce in the condom so like so that women who tried to like dig the baby juice uh they won't be able to use it to get themselves pregnant and the reason why i knew about this is because there was a lawsuit there was a lawsuit where one of the instagram models that drake hooked up with dug through the
trash can for the condom the day after and then tried to like you know get pregnant get pregnant through it but uh she ended up damaging her you know her virginie and so she tried to sue drink for endangering her body so she tried to sue drink because she was like this is your fault i fucked up my body um because you put pepper sauce hot chili pepper sauce um in the condom but like obviously what like no no of course she lost that's crazy bro that was her choice to do that she did not have to do that yeah so she lost the case because because she used trash like it was considered trash at that point
me me anyway I was the reason why I talked about this is I'm thinking do you think Harley Quinn also
anyway but yeah no that's you know it's justifiable to be super fucking paranoid too because you know you know like like these models or like these women will the fact that these women are trying to It's so scary.
There I go.
I won't leave you alone, Harley Quinn.
You know that.
Yeah, because you gotta be, like, so careful in everything.
Because they can be like, yeah, I'm on.
Yeah, of course.
Of course I'm on birth control.
And then, like, you know, they lie.
So, like, you know, it's understandable why they're so fucking paranoid about that.
The fact that they have to, like, Afterwards, they got...
Like...
It's understandable.
And then they...
They just lie about that?
That's scary, though.
You're telling me that people would lie?
I don't know.
How could they do that?
how to beat you up it was not even on the internet it's in real life I think that's the crazy part where is that they may have left some evidence that I can follow oh yeah I was gonna say what evidence oh there wait where's the evidence that radio belonged to a cop there may be evidence around here of where he was taken I should set up a crime scene alright scanning tab Joker will replace the hot sauce Mercury,
Jesus!
Honestly, I'm not even like...
Surprised.
I should follow it and see where they took him.
Alright.
Follow the blood trail.
Where does it lead?
Where is it?
I lost the blood trail.
All right, I lost the bloodshot.
I need to beat you up.
Okay, we gotta make sure.
Boom!
Get over here.
That's right, concussion!
But not terminal.
Okay, there is a blood stain here.
Okay, it's this way.
It being not terminal.
It's that bonus.
here I'm trying to follow a blood trail like it's like okay oh wait there's a sniper I'm fucking leaving goodbye here you go it's like my crumb trail I'm following the cookie trail it's my yellow brick road god damn this cop lost a lot of blood also are we even halfway
Are we even halfway to the DLC?
It's up here.
Okay, where does this trail go?
I think it's here.
Wee!
Goodbye.
Oh, I see you.
I see the trail.
It's right here.
What are we doing in here?
That's right.
Surprise, bitch.
You're guarding it for me.
Alright, informant.
Okay, wait.
I gotta kill your others.
I picked you.
Eating.
Thank you for the red.
Thank you.
That's right.
I picked you.
Wait, okay.
Give me a second.
I gotta kill him first.
Tell me how to get through that door.
Where is the Joker?
Where is he?
Wait, he said sorry.
Where is sorry?
Force of habit.
Please, I'll tell you where they are.
Just don't hurt me.
I'll do my best.
Jesus.
Okay, Batman.
He said, okay.
Harley Street to obtain the security codes.
All right, that's fine.
Where's Harley?
Alright, we'll go here first.
Yeah, he's like, I'll try not to hurt you.
Bro, he like fucking broke his neck.
Also, like, I'm still wondering where the fuck the Justice League is.
Oh, there he is.
I need to leave him until last so that he tells me what I want to know.
Oh.
Oops.
Sorry, I didn't think it would hurt him.
Sorry.
Sorry, I got too excited.
I got...
I was like, you!
Sorry, I got too excited there.
Dumbass cops should never have gotten themselves caught.
What happens now is...
Oh yeah, Goff Harley.
I just noticed.
Yeah, I noticed that too.
Oops.
I couldn't help it.
He was just so vulnerable.
You know, you know, when you're like, you're so vulnerable and then you just, you know, you just wanna kill him.
Is it though?
Oh my god, stop.
Oh god.
Okay, no.
No, we're not letting you do that.
We're not letting you do that.
I'm gonna take all of this if I have to.
Get out of here.
I have enough shit for this.
That's right.
Wait, you got your fucking gun back?
HP.
You think I care?
I got enough HP to take all of this.
Real unga bunga time.
Alright, there you go.
Now I can interrogate you.
Tell me!
I've got plot armor.
Wait,
do I not get my HP back?
Wait a minute.
Where's my HP?
Oh.
Oh, it's Continuous.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, okay.
That's all right.
Okay, now I have to actually stealth it.
Okay, so I didn't think that... Oh, wait, I get my HP back.
Yes.
Okay, JK, never punished.
Never punished.
Got it back.
Oh, my God.
He's just doing a thing that Joker did.
We can't just off the cops and get the hell out of here.
punish let's go don't worry all these snipers protecting him it doesn't matter i got you that's right do you think all these snipers are gonna save your ass i'm coming oh Oh shit, okay.
I'm still coming for you.
There you go.
Yeah, what?
Yeah, that's right.
How come I don't get the chance off one of those pigs?
Alright, get over here.
Give me the code.
Whoa!
Batman!
Some people pay extra for that back.
Batman?
Oh shit!
Oh shit, Batman!
That was crazy.
He stepped on him.
Chill, bro.
I didn't know, yeah, I didn't know Batman was like that.
For free?
all right you freeze and i'll deal with these guys
oh my god i thought i almost got the ice man we have to make sure we don't kill the ice guy
oh god damn it bro i'm trying to do my combo that's right that's what you get Letting me do my combo.
There you go.
Alright, get kicking in the head.
Alright.
Oh, hey.
Hey, what you doing?
Get frozen.
It's not your time yet.
Alright, now.
The code.
Now.
Please don't hurt me.
Here it is.
Night, night.
night buddy remember to go to the Bruce Wayne Hospital here's his card I hear they have really good coverage damn don't worry don't worry I got your phone I'll call I'll call the ambulance for you sponsored by Bruce Wayne
Any interest in playing the VR version?
Not really.
I feel like...
Okay, I think VR is so hard to stream in general.
Only because, like, people can get motion...
Like, I don't get motion sickness, but people watching it will get motion sickness, you know?
Hey, Togey.
I just fell in another lap.
Seeing a stream makes me happy.
I might do some retail therapy and buy the controller.
Wow, thank you, Superchild.
Thank you, thank you.
Hope next lab you do better, Clell.
I'm here.
Dragoons and I are here to cheer you on.
You got this.
You got to raise our average IQ.
You and all the other...
All the other STEM goons out there.
You got to raise our average IQ.
You're our only hope.
What?
We believe.
Boom!
That's right.
What the fuck?
your gun out of here.
Yeah, all five of you guys.
That's right.
Where?
No, you don't.
Get your gun out of here.
I'll get him out of here, too.
You ain't picking that gun up.
I guess you are.
I guess you are picking that gun.
Okay, bro.
Get that gun.
Get that gun out of your hand!
Get that gun out of your hand too!
Alright.
There you go.
Yoink my gun now!
God damn, he got back up so fast.
Okay, how do I get inside?
Here?
No.
It's like...
Where the fuck is the end?
Entrance?
Hello?
Am I stupid?
I am.
No, don't answer that, guys.
Where's the entrance?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Found it.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, hack time.
Hi.
Hideaway Hideaway Nice Oh Your next Batman Me?
Is it my birthday?
Oh my god she, how did she know?
Just chill out man, we're safe No one knows we're down here Oh my god, we finally got our takedown I was gonna say, it only took so long.
We finally got it.
I thought we'd never get that takedown.
A takedown.
Okay.
Oh, no, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
He has a gun.
Wait, wait.
Get over here.
Get over.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No guns.
We just gotta make sure.
Okay, guys.
Okay.
Got that.
I slammed that guy, too.
Again?
Oh.
It's okay.
Again?
Okay.
There you go.
That's fine.
He has no access to a gun.
God damn.
Come on.
So many people.
Oh, get out of here!
Oh my god, he unfroze.
No!
Not allowed.
Oh no, he's gonna throw the thing, isn't he?
Throw it!
Okay, I...
Okay, guys, I did say throw it, but I didn't think he was actually gonna throw it.
I am so dead.
Oh no, this is bad.
This is bad.
Okay.
Oh, I don't like this.
We gotta play a little pussy right now.
We got this.
We gotta play a little bit pussy.
Wait, what?!
No no no no no no no no.
Get out of here.
There you go.
That was the only gun.
Oh my god, that's not what I wanna do.
Oh god.
Okay.
Here we go.
We got the guy with the gun!
There you go.
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
Who brought the gun?
I know, right?
Oh, God, not the guy with the gun again.
Okay.
It's fine.
Slow and steady.
I don't trust myself to melee right now.
I don't trust myself.
We got it.
I'll be very careful.
I'm literally living with 1 HP.
I don't trust myself.
Okay.
There we go.
whoa whoa whoa there you go slow and steady slow and steady slow and steady wins the race okay what happened
to me that someone chuck a rock at me what happened to me
No one knows we're down here.
Okay, I don't know what happened to me.
I swear to God, that was so weird.
What the fuck happened to me?
Like, what happened?
Actually, what happened?
Okay.
Oh my god, he has a gun.
I gotta get him out of here.
What the fuck?
What did I do?
Oh, I killed him.
There you go.
Okay, we're good.
We're not good.
We're good.
We're so healthy.
20 all the way.
Jesus Christ.
There you go.
We're so good now.
Don't worry, he's not gonna throw that, right?
Okay, there you go.
It's fine.
didn't get the hit.
Get ice!
Alright, we gotta get him out, though.
Oh no.
Why won't you get me my aerial attack?
Fuck this.
There you go.
For some reason, I wouldn't let me do the aerial attack.
Okay.
Wow.
For some reason, it's a lot faster.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
I got it.
Boom!
We did it.
God, that was a lot of goons.
That was way too many goons for my liking.
Okay.
We go.
Where do we go?
Where does fuck this Harley Quinn want me to do?
Like, where are the cops?
Where are the cops?
What the fuck?
I have to rescue the cops, but I don't know where the cops are.
Okay, not here.
Okay, that's good.
That limits the area.
I'm gonna put my tag on the next bank ski.
Bat ski.
Bat ski is here.
here.
Oh.
Okay.
Uh.
Baski is here.
For real now.
Okay.
Is this here?
Oh, pop.
All right.
It has to be through this door.
There's no other way.
Hello?
Harley.
i didn't mean to kill your boyfriend to be fair he was my boyfriend first like to be fair so like i'm also not i'm also suffering with you
like we the same girl i mean look around if i don't kill you one of my friends up there will go on take a look you see those sniper rifles real nasty i hear
Okay, okay, that's not cool.
Is this silent enough?
Okay.
It's fine.
We got rid of the sniper.
Boom!
Okay, I didn't realize the sniper had people.
I didn't realize the sniper had friends, okay?
I messed up.
Oh my God, what the fuck you mean?
I, oh my God, get me in the, get me through.
Oh my God, security area to continue.
Okay, this is bad.
This is so bad.
Oh, a balloon.
Yeah.
Oh my God, I'm just getting shotgun.
Oh my God, it's everywhere.
It's everywhere.
It's a plan.
Look at that, it's a, it worked.
Stay calm, everyone.
I told you guys, it works.
If it works, it works, guys.
He'll never turn around.
I don't think...
What do you mean?
Negative stealth guys.
I won.
I won Can't be negative if I win Bam it's over It worked see I'm so stealthy Don't worry.
I got you you see that it was pretty cool wasn't it bro I
Minus one to a hundred.
Oh shit.
What?
Oh, that's how you got my gadgets.
Oh, the trackers.
Oh, that's right.
That's my DNA.
Only my DNA can wear the belt.
Oh, so that's what happened.
Like, how do I get a concussion from a chest?
Like, how do I pass out?
It hit my chest, not my head.
What's going on?
Have you found him?
Yeah, but I have a bulletproof army.
Don't worry.
Did my heart fucking stop?
Yeah, there's no vital organs on the chest.
Exactly.
Batman?
Five minutes with a bat.
That's all I need.
Payback.
Joker he's just up there right what's stopping you nothing I guess then do it much in that room to climb up and teach Batman a lesson we'll watch yeah I took 57 sniper shots and I'm I was fine I thought he's got a plan don't want to get in the way do I do I know I sneak through this yeah I don't think I can
Robin smash!
Oh, shit.
That's right!
Boom!
Okay, I don't know if this actually, like...
I don't know if that actually, like, does anything.
Does it even kill?
Like, I don't fucking know.
Alright.
There you go.
That's right.
Bam, bam, bam.
I feel like a stick can cause more damage than fists.
Not gonna that.
If anything, I'm pretty sure I can cause, like, brain bleed.
So the fact that Robin is so confident that these goons are gonna be okay is very surprising.
There you go.
I want to make sure I get that hit.
All right, yeah, I think like a stick is like easier to get brain brain hemorrhages I didn't kill them the brain killed him Okay, wait Boom All right, that should be all of them, right?
All right, knock knock.
Oh, hey everyone.
Oh, that's not creepy at all Thank God.
Yeah, and some metal staff, too.
Quinn's got him trapped.
Harley's built some kind of monument to the Joker, and it's stopping me from getting to Batman.
Looking at this place, she's crazier than we thought.
I'm going to search the area and try to work out how to save him.
Dead bat.
One chart.
Joker forever.
Oh, that's not...
This is like misa-misa-shit type shit.
No, 100%.
Security panel appears to control the statue.
Batman will die in there if I don't find a key.
I guess I should go find Harley Quinn and ask her for it.
Oh.
Obtain the key card.
It's like Misa Misa.
Oh my god, it's so far.
Okay, we are.
That's me.
Where's he getting, like, lack of air?
Okay.
Damn it.
He's trapped in that thing.
Oh, it is lack of air.
Yeah.
I don't have much time.
He's running out of air.
Yeah, I was gonna say, is there no air holes in there?
That makes sense.
Yeah, just a little hee hee ha ha.
Wait, am I actually timed?
There's no way.
Someone just said he can, like, meditate for three days.
It's not like it took me three days to find him.
I need to find Harley Quinn or Batman will die in that.
Is that not where I have to go?
Oh, through here?
I thought I could get through.
Okay, never mind.
Oh, I am timed?
Oh, shit, Batman.
I'm sorry, bro.
Oh, shit, I was not paying attention.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, Dad.
Found anything?
Nah, it's just full of crap.
Wait, what?
Okay, that's fine.
I still got the silent takedown.
Don't worry, he's waiting a little bit.
It's okay.
If Batman dies, I inherit.
I inherit the Bruce Wayne fortune.
So technically...
If you think about it...
Wait.
Alright, here I'll go.
It's fine.
don't worry i'm slowly heading over oh shit okay wait wait guys wait wait this is important i got it oh my god everyone stop stop
all i'm saying it would be i mean if if dad dies i still i inherit the bruce wane fortune So is it truly that bad?
Damien hasn't been born yet.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is bad.
How are you?
Oh my god.
There's a bit of a...
Fuck the sniper.
Actually.
Fuck this guy in general.
We actually get rid of the sniper in general.
The sniper is the...
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's fine.
I messed up because the sniper was like...
The sniper was so annoying.
I didn't do this again.
Okay, he doesn't know.
Who the hell is this fool?
All right.
Yeah, Damien hasn't been born yet.
Less to split.
Less inheritance to split, guys.
I don't know.
Oh, there's a vent here.
There he is.
Maybe I should have been in the vent.
Yeah.
I didn't even notice there was a vent.
Where do I go?
Do I just go through this door?
Where?
Like this?
Oh!
What the fuck?
You mean we could have done that this entire time?
Oops.
There we go.
Fuck you.
Your stupid ass gun.
No, we get you out.
here first that's right i don't care i don't know we're getting this guy out of here there we go
yeah all right we got this that's right i will blind you i don't care
come on get out here that's right get out
That's right.
You think that helmet's gonna solve anything?
Alright.
Nice.
We made it.
My bat vision doesn't see anything.
My bird vision.
Where do I go?
What the fuck is this?
Oh, okay.
Oh my god, there's so many vents.
Oh,
I have an idea.
I don't have an idea.
Where is she?
Oh, she's up there.
Bro, she's so far.
How the fuck?
Bro, she's so fucking far.
Guys, I don't have an idea.
I thought I did, but this is bullshit.
Do I have to...
to take down everybody or do they spawn forever just like the last yeah do
they spawn forever I
don't think they know I'm here oh okay I didn't realize there's a fucking tight bro all
right here we go we're fine now don't worry watch this
That's right.
Goodbye.
Turned your back on me.
That's okay, right?
You fucked up, buddy.
It shouldn't have turned your back.
Oh, shit.
that's right I got you now girl that's oh shit okay that's not what I was okay okay okay okay smoke pellet oh wait that's okay there you go where am I oh my god That's where I am Guys, I don't know where I am.
Oh Where am I?
Oh shit.
Oh It's okay.
It's okay Everything's fine
Guys, we gotta keep it together guys He took a hostage
There's no way you'll kill the hostage right
There's no way right That's messed up Okay I got an idea
Oh You don't even know where I am Oh my god don't worry Don't worry I got you bro Oh Okay, don't worry.
I got you.
I'll save your life.
Don't worry.
I swear.
Bro, if Morgan doesn't do it!
Wait, that's messed up!
How the fuck am I supposed to save his life?
Oh, shit!
Oh, that's awkward.
That's...
Bro, I can't fucking go in around him!
Don't worry, I'll save you.
How the fuck was I supposed to know that?
Oh, shit, smoke pellet!
I'll get him out first.
I just want to get this guy out.
Oh, shit.
Nope.
Open sesame.
Where am I?
No.
What
happened?
Oh my god, what happened guys?
That's fucking right.
She's in the vents.
Where did that go?
He's in the vents guys.
Come on.
You could have stayed in the vents, bro.
You could.
Bro, you.
Why you gotta ruin the fun, bro.
You could have stayed in the vents.
It would have been so fun.
You could have had such a good old time.
This is a jolly old time in the vents.
You and me.
Okay, the last sniper is right here.
What the fuck?
Why is he over there now?
There we go.
And that's everyone.
Oh no, there's one more guy.
Where is he going?
I don't even know where he's going.
Whoa.
Corner!
That's right!
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
We spawn indefinitely.
Corner again!
Wait a minute!
You spawn forever!
Come on.
Oh, shit.
Come on, you can't do that forever.
I know you can.
There we go.
Oh my god, she escaped to a vantage point.
Oh, this is not good.
This is not good.
No, no!
Oh, God!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, okay, okay, oh, God, okay,
there you go,
there you go, there's no plan, there's no plan, all right, here you go, get off me, Oh, that was close.
You'll never find it.
He'll never search between the bobs.
Whoa, Robin.
Whoa.
Robin.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's crazy, Robin.
You gotta ask the women's permission first.
Alright, this way.
It's for justice.
So it's fine.
Alright, this way.
Oh, what?
What's up there?
That's not cool.
Come back to play.
Oh my god!
Bro, even he's here?
Oh, this is not good for me.
Wait, this is not good for me yet.
Oh god, guys, guys, there's a lot.
There's a lot.
Okay, as long as he...
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh my god, guys, guys, guys, I'm not okay.
I'm...
Oh no.
I don't have eyes like my dad.
Okay, we'll just use him to kill everyone.
This is it.
That's it.
I'll use him to kill him.
Okay, it's perfectly aligned, big bro.
There we go.
All right, it's perfectly aligned just for you.
Come on.
Are you serious?
Okay, that's fine.
There we go.
a line of kill me too does he even kill anyone I
don't even know if he's killing anyone is he actually killing anyone or am I just wasting time bro I know I have to hold counter bro just oh it does it does it does it does do you see that did you see that oh my god he's chucking his own oh my god it actually is like bowling.
Wait, it's working!
It's working!
Okay, okay, it's actually working.
It actually is like bowling.
I think it's like the only way I can deal with this.
Oh my god, okay.
He's not running as fast as I would like.
There you go.
It works.
The strategy works.
I just need to make bait them early in the group.
There you go.
All right, here's more.
Here's more.
Bullying.
All right, come on.
Come on, you got this.
Oh, oh, oh my God.
It's actual bullying now.
All right.
Split.
Not a strike yet, bro.
Not a strike.
Oh, no.
A reverse bowling.
Alright, here we go.
This is the only way.
There's way too many people.
Come on.
Come on, he's going to get another bowling ball.
Another strike.
Are you going to get a strike?
It's okay.
Batman's 5.
He's so healthy.
Alright, maybe I should try helping out now.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, unless...
Nice, okay, that's a lot of people down.
See, it helped!
No, I needed to kill all those people.
See, look at that!
Now it's me and him.
There we go.
I told you!
Now it's just me and him.
I told you it works.
Boom!
I did it.
I got a strike.
I got the Wii Sport high score.
Wait, he could have just done that?
Hey, Dad.
What kept you?
I'm fucking sorry.
Where's your other son's not here to save your life?
Nightwing didn't come.
That's it.
You saved the cops.
I'll handle the bombs.
Wait, I have to handle the mobs?
Oh no, I don't.
Nice.
If you use the bomb, I got this.
I got this.
Dead, mad, fat.
Okay.
The workings of this bomb look familiar.
I need to shut it down.
Then examine it.
That's it?
Oh, that's easy.
What the fuck?
The bombs have been built using explosives stolen from the GCPD lockup last year.
week harley quinn hasn't changed the detonation frequency i'll calibrate the cowl to locate any other objects tuned into this frequency yeah just just punch the bomb
this way it's just that easy i just okay tim tim i thought tim i thought we agreed that you would you handle the the goons why are there goons here tim
What happened?
Then what happened?
We had one job!
You literally had one job!
This way.
What the fuck?
There's a sniper?
Oh shit.
That's fine.
That's fucking right, bitch.
Alright.
Here we go.
Gotta go this way.
Here?
Oh, there it is.
There you go.
Oh my god, how many bombs did she do?
Murderer.
Alright, another bomb down.
Boom!
Oh, Tim is rescuing the cops.
Oh, okay.
I thought we had a deal.
We're like...
Oh, yeah.
this way.
I thought you said you handle the goons.
I didn't realize he said the cops.
You guys?
Good question.
Guys, come on.
Come on.
This is it.
Bro, okay.
We all die if it explodes.
Okay.
Yeah, you don't remember it.
We all die.
Oh my god.
That's it.
I think he forgot that we all die here.
Jesus Christ, that was a lot of damage.
Alright, now I can kill him.
Get over here.
Oh my god, it's this way.
Open, open, open.
Oh god, where is it?
Wait, how do I get over here?
What?
Oh, shit!
It's here, it's here, it's here, it's here!
Oh my god.
There you go, there you go, there you go.
I forgot about this area.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, bats!
No!
Okay, I can't tag more than one.
Okay.
Forever.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
I forgot, like, I'm Batman this time.
Because Tim's going to do shit.
Joker forever.
Yuki's here to save us.
We're doomed.
Absolutely.
It was a super chat.
Thank you.
Return to Joker's stride.
I have to go all the way.
God damn it, Harley.
Why can't I just leave?
I've been fucking backtracked all the way back to your goddamn creepy-ass stride.
I thought we done.
And this way.
I have to go.
back to a creepy ass shrine okay
all right I'm coming over Harley all right what is it am I fighting this Mecca oh god all right it's a Mecca fight now oh wait what the fuck this Bioshock Tad wait they okay I was gonna say do they not.
Okay, I was gonna say, can I not counter robots?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's so many combos.
It never stops.
That's right.
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
32, 34, 36.
That's right.
Oh, it stopped.
I was gonna say nothing has stopped me.
And that stopped.
Ooh, it thought.
Wait, it doesn't even tell me when I can counter them.
That's fine.
That's right, you don't get to join in on fun.
That's why we're going forever.
No fun for you.
Okay, nice.
I'll keep going!
It never stops!
Until it does, like right now.
Oh shit.
I just don't miss.
Hey.
There's no way she'll expect this, right?
How the fuck?
What if I just grapple you?
What if I just keep grappling?
requires key card to unlock oh what what
can I counter it oh I thought like legitimately I didn't realize I counter it oh my god just grab her foot grab your foot I don't know it was just that easy I don't know I thought it'd be so hard I didn't realize I could just grab her I thought it would be much more difficult.
She could just, I was like, I didn't realize it'd be that easy!
I didn't realize!
It seems like it would be the hardest boss fight of my life, but I just grabbed her for me.
I don't know, I assume a boss fight would be hard.
Quiet.
Where's Robin?
I thought he was with you.
I got your toes.
Hey, where is Robin?
This entire job was to save the cops.
What have you done?
Now you know how it feels.
Robin?
Oh, shit.
Oh, he's alive!
Just got up.
Got it just in time.
Yay!
Hey, kid.
Is he alright?
Yeah, sure.
Bro, he dresses like a bat.
You really think he's okay?
Birderang!
Oh, dang!
it oh my god okay it's here someone in my chat was like depends on how fast it will take you for the boss fight so i remember someone said that because i was like oh how long is the dlc and someone in my chat was like well it'll be one to two hours depending on how long it's gonna take you on the last boss fight so in my head i didn't i thought it'd be like some fucking elaborate shit against harley but i didn't realize just grab her feet like
I was like, oh yeah, surely I have to do like 20 things before I get to it.
I, it was right.
Yeah, the hardest boss, but yeah.
Oh, that was fun.
I can't believe we managed to finish a DLC too, because usually we skip the DLC part.
But you know what?
I felt like, you know, we finished the game in two hours, like for two hours, I figured like and we spent like an hour of that like yapping so i was just like you know what i'll throw in a dlc too um just because like um just because you know i finished the game a lot faster than i thought i would anyway i've had a lot of fun playing batman um you know i enjoy i enjoyed the jokies weakness feed absolutely thank you the super chat thank you thank you i have always enjoyed dc lore i've I've always enjoyed DC comics and all the...
You know, I've always been a DC gal versus a Marvel gal, despite, you know, I play a lot of Marvel rivals.
I still enjoy DC more in terms of, like, story-wise, the comics, story, and the film.
Jesus Christ, why is this music so scary?
Also, is there an after-credit scene?
Chat, is there an after-credit scene, guys, for this?
I just think I don't know I personally think the I personally think like DC villains are more um they're more what's the word uh like they're more memorable than Marvel villains like I'm like the first to be fair a lot of the DC villains are also mostly from Batman but distinct and iconic yeah they're a lot more iconic and distinct because like I'm thinking Marvel villains that I know this that's really it a lot of Marvel villains are also more so of like anti-heroes like you know you could be like oh yeah what about Loki but he's like an anti-hero now um but if I think about like DC villains I'll be like oh there's the Riddler there's Joker there's Lex Luthor um like there's uh there's two-faced there's um reverse flash
bane like i felt like a lot i a lot i mean there is dr doom but like i don't know i don't think dr doom is that i don't think dr doom is like that what's it called i i find his personality and backstory not as interesting as a dc villain um that's how i feel when i think of dr doom um i And like,
and then there's, uh, well, Magneto is more like an anti-hero, because he thinks he, what he's doing is for the good, you know, like, he thinks he's doing good things, you know, like, it's not like he tries to be a villain, he just hates all humankind,
which is understandable, because he's a fucking mutant, he's a disgusting mutant, sorry, um, I'm, That's a joke.
Slash JK.
I'm joking.
I'm joking, guys.
Poor mutant cat.
Now he would kill me.
What do you mean?
Now we know your side.
He would kill me.
If I am face to face with Magneto, because I am human, quote unquote, human I would just be dead like so um so yeah like I'm just thinking like I felt like I feel like those DC villains are much also because Marvel is now owned by Disney so they're so they're so clean they're so like oh what's the word when you know when disney owns something they try not to be risky with anything they're so they're so like cautious with whatever yeah they're so sanitized and cautious and watered down with what they want to do with marvels but dc they they go fucking crazy now with their lore and everything because they're no not owned by disney because they don't want you know they don't want to be like a mark like disney wants to be more like oh for the children you know you gotta we can't be like too crazy because we don't want to set a bad example to the kids um but like in dc it's just like they just throw on the wall and it works like and they're like as long as disney doesn't buy warner bros
we're okay but i'm scared i'm that it is still a possibility because like disney is slowly buying every fucking property in existence so i'm a little scared because like warner bros um is apparently gonna be sold again
yeah i know the ceo for like warren boas is not the best because you know they did they canceled like you know the wildy coyote shit and everything but at least it's not owned by disney at least it's not owned by disney that's like the little things uh captain eight ball they give a super chat thank you thank you uh i don't even remember but i said i was gonna send you some comments i hadn't had time i was wondering why you're what you were interested in i'm gonna add some random stuff like no not the harley quinn fart comic oh i remember someone i remember seeing that on twitter oh my it was because it was written by some fetish artist too like from fetish art third i was super into farts as well god that's so bad thank you this super chat captain april thank you thank you i'm what is it called deceased i really enjoy i haven't finished reading the sequels to deceased i finished reading the first the first um um arc for deceased but i didn't read the sequels yet i stopped when like
they start they like left earth that's where i stopped uh oh you guys didn't know that yeah they had um dc did like a rage bait comment where they made entire comic series based off of harley quinn fighting it's i there's nothing else i can say like
I could explain more but there's no thing else to explain that's the context like and it was released on crew it was it's like this is not a joke by the way this is yeah
yeah so yeah it's called Harley Quinn for fartacular it's silent but deadly oh my god how many comics was there for this like how many did they yeah it's not it's i wish it was rage bait it's it's not it was literally the artist's quick uh kink too like it was his fetish or her fetish i think it was her fetish i'm pretty sure i think it was written by a woman um which is very surprising you know because you know she was she was suppressing a lot All right,
let's see, I'll read a review.
All right.
It's sort of, okay, wait, what?
Maybe this is sort of body positivity comedy.
So let's try to justify it.
You're like, maybe it's body positivity.
I don't know.
Oh, like, recommend it if you're a fan of any sort of Harley Quinn slapstick comedy, no matter what, you're into farts.
You're like, really into farts.
Okay, Harley Quinn Partacular Silent But Deadly is an unsettling mixture of childish humor and fetishist sexual innuendo, seemingly only meant to appeal to those who truly love every experience related to farting.
For the small subset of fans out there who fall under that category, I assume they'll be very happy.
For everyone else, it's a deeply uncomfortable experience.
one out of ten it's like yeah one out of ten
okay but it is yeah that score no I think like if he could he would give a lower score if this person could
that's crazy things are killing it's Not even my fight was Captain.
Golden, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It was me.
I thought the final fight was in the docs, everything.
After that fight was white from my brain.
I just remember being stuck in that fight.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Gam, thank you, the super chat.
The R-Side looks kind of like I am, oh, yeah, I remember that.
I remember that Starfire.
I remember that comic.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Loki, like the controller.
But why did you remind me of that freaking comic?
it wasn't even me that reminded you it was one of your own it wasn't even me it was one of your own oh yeah by the way since like tomorrow um is the marvel rival's early access stream um which i'll be doing on twitch as always i'll be on the team with tim the tatman um i think our team is like sort of fucked in terms of in bat like sort of fucked in terms of imbalances because the enemy fighting it's like necros super um for those who are like are into you know know like the skill level of everybody it's necros super kg samju lulu and um oh my god who's the sixth person um i don't remember i don't remember the sixth and then my team is me ninja tim uh craiggy uh and j j3 and last because like their team has like has oh yeah and flats sorry and flats is on the other team so like their team has more players who are top 500 but my team's vibe though my team's vibe anyway so I tried out so they there's this new update in rivals um there's this new update on rivals that's coming up for the
next season and it's basically they basically added like chill or kill lobby so like you know to get people out of doom doom queues so like not all the role players can move to the chiller like move to like town square and they can hold up to like a hundred players so so like there's like yeah and there's ads on that map it's crazy because i was testing up the i was testing out the game today um before uh before like uh tomorrow because i want to make sure everything works and like when you go to time square it literally plays from Disney Plus like because I was like what the fuck is that sound why am I hearing like actual people talking like like like a show and then I look to the right and the monitor is playing like Wanda like a WandaVision ad like to be like check out Disney Plus like check out WandaVision on Disney Plus and I was like what the fuck so apparently and I read I read that like when you're in town square time square it will play various like shows like ads and stuff to
like from disney plus yeah yeah and i don't think you can turn the volume down i'm not sure i think i think you can't turn the volume down too for the for the tv i won't be able to say it tomorrow by the way because obviously i can't say anything negative but like i wanted to talk about it Because,
like, obviously, I can't mention it tomorrow.
If I wanted to mention it today, I thought it was a little weird.
I do think that's a little weird.
Like, I'm trying to role play.
And fucking, and fucking the Avengers is playing on the TV.
Yeah, yeah, I'm like, I'm, it's turning my immersion right now.
yeah um tom thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you i know like accurate time square honestly very accurate time square experience uh tom thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you the harley quinn comic reminds me of bruce tim's batman film where harley quinn teams up with batman robin and there was a part where she fired it robin was grossed up but batman said it's our oh my god there's no way is that real there's no i know bruce tim had like weird weird remember exactly what it was some someone can uh can uh remind me i know we have some lore masters here that can remind me what it is but uh i remember uh bruce tim was a freak but i don't remember oh yeah bruce tim the horniest dc writer why there's a thorn why doesn't bruce tim the horniest comic for it this was 2018 jesus christ oh my um oh yeah because he ships batman and batgirl that's fucking weird it's weird oh my god okay now guys i remember now i i oh yeah oh yeah because like um he bat uh bruce
tim makes batman a goddamn whore
um i forgot about that this is basically like if there's a woman bruce is bruce tim is like that's for batman batman's coming in yeah see this is all like like he's like if there's a woman that's for batman
Um, that's, yeah, no, no, some DC writers are, are freaks, guys.
Some, even Lois Lane, not in front of, not in front of Clark, Bruce.
Bruce Wayne is a Bruce Wayne.
Bro, he's got everybody, bro, he's a player.
Do you guys know he's a playboy?
He's a, what the fuck?
Wait, there is no way.
There is no way this is official artwork from Bruce.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait, give me a sec.
I gotta see if this is official artwork from Mr. Bruce.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
I found a... I found an artwork from a foreign, but I'm... I'm concerned.
I cannot show it on stream because it is very...
bad is the bat quen kiss scene the uncensored version by Bruce Tim there's no okay there's no way this is no there's
I I just do it okay i can't say exactly what i saw but i saw some of bruce tim's sketches that are very unfilled uncensored
and he really really let me just say he really really likes Harley Quinn.
That's...
Oh my god.
Wow.
No, he's a freak.
No, okay.
No, he's a fucking freak.
No, 100%.
That guy's a fucking freak.
Holy fuck.
That...
Whoa.
Just...
If you...
For those who wanna...
I would say it is not safe for work.
It is very not safe for work.
If you guys...
Anyone who's curious, I did not realize this, but wow.
Now I understand.
He is definitely the horniest DC writer.
He is, oh my God.
He is the, oh my God.
I can't believe he's created all these shows.
I, I can't believe, no wonder they made her leave, Joker.
Oh, oh my God.
No, how did he, oh my God.
I'm so sad that he created all my childhood shows.
Oh my God.
I'm, I'm so sad.
He created Batman Beyond.
I'm so sad.
No!
He's looking me through the window.
Never beat your ears.
Never.
I didn't realize.
I didn't realize his dark side.
His inner beast.
He kept his inner beast locked down.
He did.
He had so much respect.
strength guys you really did anyway guys oh my god anyways i'm gonna call it here um tomorrow is the sponsor stream on twitch it will be marvel rivals um we're doing the early access come on gabin is so hard oh my god like he is holy shit he is he hurts my brain i'll say that but you'll understand you guys are gonna understand tomorrow he hurts my brain but anyway guys guys as he support no he support anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to keep that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody all right guys bye